all right and we are live the last word
lord cognito ibontes and ty guy travis
on that thursday evening campfire
major show amazing guest lined up let's
start first with e how you doing sir
doing good dabbling in a little bit of
that whole halo thing that magically
dropped on monday and broke the internet
so i got a little bit of that in
uh i've got a little bit of practice to
do because that's a different game
time to kill is a different animal in
there so get a feel for it play with a
couple of buddies um
yeah that's a different different animal
but definitely something to get used to
it is very smooth i think after like
maybe the first hour like it's been very
smooth very polished feels pretty good
and then i got to read it like so i
don't read books as much as i probably
should guaranteed but i think i got my
reading in for today which we're going
to talk about here in just a little bit
so i definitely consume some words
sometimes but maybe not always in books
travis what about you man
i'm trying to go fast because today is
going to be yeah today we're going to
play a long show get through it man i'll
get through it uh yeah i like you i've
been playing a ton of halo i'm doing
cover try g and i'm helping them with
video capture and with the wiki i'm
creating the multiplayer tips guide so
if you ever want to know how to be a
sweat lord at halo infinite multiplayer
i created the uh the tips guide there so
i'm having to play a lot and trying to
figure out secrets and stuff that people
don't know usually do you want it do you
want a good tip
sure something i've been crunching if
you have the i think it's the mangler
the ravager the uh the shotgun pistol
one yeah one shot to the body melee
kills every time
so i've been just kind of you just camp
in the corner
it's as close to destiny as you're
getting halo
have you guys gotten the uh have you
guys figured out about the um the
armories that you can hack into on in
big team battle yeah and they open up
like a big rocket launcher instead it
has these doors off to the sides that
you can put your ai in and if you stay
there for like 30 seconds and guard the
area it'll hack open a door and then it
leads to an area with all these loot
drops and you can just send your whole
team in there and like loot up with
snipers and gravity yeah i noticed that
at one point i got to loot it out
yeah so you can you can read about that
on my tips guide and other cool tips uh
yeah i've been playing a lot of halo
i've been playing a lot of forza i'm
catching up on all of my
game of the year nominees games that i
have to uh i was like i really want to
talk about the game all the nominations
but we're not going to not have time we
don't have time we're going to save that
for
another time short version is because of
the weakness of the award nominations my
job just got a lot easier in terms of
the games i have to beat this year um so
i'm happy about that but also kind of
yeah and yeah the uh that that's that's
pretty much what i'm doing and obviously
uh stoked about all this destiny news
sir what about you man yeah it's very
good man i mean uh no no no other
podcasts you do nothing else you've been
playing
no there's nothing going on with me
yo a halo job perfectly on the birthday
tremendous gift seriously i was like
love oh it was perfect i was rocking
that out um and the 49ers win by the way
i did want to show that was good
i was like oh they're playing the rams
we're not going to win i'm like
okay okay i was like all right blow out
okay incognito did you see that double
get in the double here yeah yeah
it was it was a glorious day yes
so we got that and then yeah the little
forza horizon sneaking that in i
finished uh forgotten city which was
amazing
i've heard really good things yeah yeah
that's how you do it yeah yeah
i know that but that's how you do time
loop so i was happy with that and then
uh some destiny news drop today but
before we get into that we got like this
amazing returning guest we got to deal
with this let's do it how we do it here
at the campfire welcome to the last word
episode number one 74. the weather is
getting colder turkeys will soon be the
centerpiece of many family tables and
there has never been a better time to
not be under the activision umbrella as
guardians we are usually
shot by it
oh god
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah continue continue sorry sorry i
don't know if i can follow that up but
we're gonna try
as guardians we are usually prepared for
most things but today bungie dropped
possibly the biggest twab of them all
and we have a special returning guest to
join us at the campfire for what i will
expect to be a hashtag longpoint of a
podcast if you know you know
our guest tonight knows patience
persistence and determination pay off
better than most right now he's working
on his phd in polymer chemistry and in
case that isn't clear what that is to
focus on everything from plastic to
rubber and dna basically everything
that's made up of macromolecules this
man has worked his tail off to prove
that he is worth
being called doctor and if you have ever
seen his streams you know he will not
stop until he succeeds no matter what he
puts his mind to just ask him how long
it took to solo atheon and you'll know
that he is just like ted lasso and won't
quit something until he crosses the
finish line so let's welcome a man of
true taste one who holds ocarina of time
in high regards and would put vault of
glass on the bottom shelf a man of
ranking exotics or sorry a master of
ranking exotics huge contributor to the
corridors of time puzzle lover of baby
scream a fan of a very dingy emote and
owner of some of the most luscious
flowing locks that are always ready for
a good headbanging if some metal graces
his ears so let's welcome the one the
only scarod9 how are you doing sir i'm
doing very well as always unbelievable
interest it's incredible so thank you
and i like the uh i like the uh the
research on what polymer chemistry is i
appreciate that i i was like i
probably gave it a really crappy
description but i had to look it up a
little bit
from uh from
very excellent description of uh uh you
know elevator pitch of what polymer
chemistry is so it was good
um
yeah what's up everyone how are you
doing yeah good job
bro i've just been vibing trying to
survive
and he's blowing out his vocal cords
when he beats bosses getting married
like jamming on the guitar like
seriously is there anything you're not
doing
uh sleeping
yeah
that fits pretty well yeah
i'm excited to uh you know i only have
about a year and a half left in my
program and nice i'm excited for that to
be over because then i get like a real
person job with real person pay hey
sleep and that's like
very excited for that very nice very
nice i wanted to ask you if the world of
like polymer chemistry like what is some
of the like one or two of like the
coolest like either interactions between
chemicals things that you've learned
about stuff like random facts that
you're like damn nobody knows this and
it's like some of the coolest things
like you got any of those that's
probably too many
that's really hard to oh i don't think
people like
i mean most people don't like realize
you know what a palmer is or or you know
how uh crazy they are
um but i mean it's anything like you
know shopping bags or polyethylene you
have like
advanced shakers hey definitely a
sponsor thank you shout out to advanced
properly
yeah um yeah those are usually made out
of polypropylene if i had the gas you
know polymers are everywhere you know
you have rubbers on on headphones and
usually uh they're coated with some sort
of brominated palmer so they're not
flammable and stuff and i it's just kind
of crazy
how much goes in into it behind the
scenes that like people are just like oh
yes this is plastic that's plastic this
is plastic but they're you know all
different stuff and that's what i really
like about it but in terms of like
random facts i have no idea i i honestly
i don't know do you
do you have like
i don't know a favorite
chemical like or my favorite chemical
look at that
so i commonly say that my favorite we so
solvents are you know you dissolve
things in solvents to run reactions
because typically you can't do reactions
in solid state they have to be in uh
solution state um and so my favorite
solvent is dmso dimethyl sulfoxide um
it's really good for dissolving things
it's one the most so people call like
water the universal solvent that's not
true for like organic molecules just for
mostly salts and stuff uh dmso is a is
really so everything's pretty much
soluble in the mso and assassins used to
use it they would dissolve their poison
a little bit of dmso and put on
doorknobs and so when people would touch
the doorknob it would go through the
people's skin because
yeah your skin is soluble in the mso so
it would just kind of like
soak through
uh and
dmso isn't toxic but you know the poison
is and so there have been assassinations
that way but also if you get dmso and
your rubbing on your feet you taste
garlic in your mouth so that's great
what
random is what that's crazy yeah
there's a lot of really cool like it's i
don't know it's one of those things i
can't pull up facts but you get me
talking and i'll be it starts going nice
yeah what can you tell us about uh
chemical x
how i might mix with sugar and spice
oh is this uh this is a reference i
don't get i have no idea what the hell
chemical x is
savagery
what i was gonna say how you been as far
as game playing and stuff like obviously
we know you you're married to dusty for
a lot of time but um has anything else
snuck yet i know you mentioned haley hey
leo halo appreciate it yeah yeah paleo
destiny is definitely where i spend most
of my time um but halo my friends were
bugging me about it i so i played when
the master chief collection came out
like five or six years ago or whatever i
played all the campaigns but i've never
played like a halo multiplayer
and so when this dropped on monday and
my friends were like it's free it's free
it's free i was like all right i'll
download it whatever and i've been like
it's so much fun i
i really thrive in these high time to
kill environments i think like my strong
suit fast reaction time and kind of like
out playing that's a little bit
egotistical but you know like really
we're doing like really uh intricate
like movements and stuff and in a game
like destiny or especially call of duty
you don't really have the time to do
that it's like in call of duty
especially like you get shot you're just
you're just dead yeah yeah but yeah
yeah and halo you know if someone has
like a gun that's like a little bit
better for the ranged engagement or
something you know you can do a lot more
to get multi kills and stuff so i've
been having a lot of fun especially in
the competitive playlist
okay
and uh yeah i'm excited i don't know
i've uh
been getting
sorry no i was gonna say any loadouts
that's exciting you right now i know you
mentioned like any other guns right now
that's just you know they're feeling
good you're loving certain combos yeah
uh so i'm a big fan of the battle rifle
i what for whatever reason i i'm like a
mid sniper at best in destiny in halo
that thing sticks to heads i'm mouse and
keyboard too and like i like i'm just
such a good sniper in halo and i don't
understand it it's really confusing but
uh battle rifle i like comp as well
because you spawn with the battle rifle
not that garbage assault rifle i cannot
stand that thing it's so bad
um
and then the assault rifle no i hate it
it's like it's a good card
because it's so good it's better see
what it is you're new to halo right
right yeah this is out of your first one
so like he has like i know what you're
being trans like he doesn't know what it
used to be so for us we like oh it's
actually decent it's pretty it's pretty
good
if somebody's got a br and you're
fighting you're fighting with an assault
rifle at close range the assault rifle
is going to win which is the main
purpose of it it's for like ultra close
range if i'm playing like regular quick
play or what i forget i don't know what
it's called yeah the regular game modes
um i'll switch to the pistol every time
like i think the pistol is better than
this
oh yeah don't worry about it
yeah i'm a pistol pete kind of guy right
now
but anytime i see like there's that
weird purple circle thing that she's
green i leave that no it sucks i'm not
touching it there's the one that shoots
like giant fire pools i have no idea how
it works not touching it
yeah yeah it's like i i pick like the
normie guns that i can run around
shotgun meleeing people
most people do yeah
also is is what's up with grenades in
halo why do you get 12 or it's like two
every time you respawn but it's constant
it's crazy
it's like that's kind of the secret
sauce of halo is that they the blam
engine has like grenades so perfectly
tuned so where you can like bounce them
off of objects and around edges and
stuff like that around corners and
so they just give you a ton of different
grenade options oh well there you go
it's uh i it is a little frustrating at
times but it is it's also kind of fun
just to like sticky nade across the map
see what you can do you know
or the the fallen grenades i don't know
what they're i don't know what any halo
terminology i'm always like get the
fallen grenades
i know what you're talking about yeah
yeah they're like those things are crazy
they're so good yeah actually if you
yeah it's funny that this is like new to
halo because there's a ton or there's a
ton of like destiny
stuff that is sort of like owed to halo
and knowing about the halo sandbox can
actually help you in a lot of investing
in certain ways like oh there you go i
uh
definitely been missing out on that
forever so
i i i've been having a lot of fun i i
definitely get the height behind halo
uh i think it is a great oh
it's the one thing that halo i've i've
really been thinking about playing halo
is like why does destiny not have more
fun game modes like where's an oddball
in destiny where's an old i remember
like pod four
had old fashioned which is the same
thing as halo where you spawn with like
a default loadout and there's guns that
spawn around the map like destiny can
you could literally do that with exotics
yeah why is there not a gun game in
destiny where you spawn with an exotic
heated kill and you have to cycle
through 20 exhausts oh my gosh somebody
sleeps you could do sticks and stones
with swords and
bows or something like there are so many
things you could do in destiny but it's
like you know hey rift not coming back
um
salvage not coming back it's like rift
rift is coming back
yeah three years later actually it's
been way too long yeah yeah but i don't
know i get you that's like it's it's so
weird because halo is the exact opposite
where they're adding modes so often
their problem is that their their
playlists get too like saturated and
people are like come on take out some of
these modes there's like so many and
yeah and usually usually uh 343 goes nah
not like we're keeping them all
right and i kind of love that about halo
but i think a part of it is their
culture because halo has always had a
custom games option where you can make
your own game modes and a lot of those
game modes become popular so much money
for that i'm like like oh my god dude
like i asked about that
for years everything was just
headquarters private games was such a
sad
thing to see because you're like oh you
can pick the map and the length of it
match i'm like you can't pick anything
else do you have any idea how much
people would have destiny one you could
pick the time of day don't forget that
this yeah things depending on some maps
that may change but like let me pick
like oh you know just these weapons or
certain like you could do some like the
forge mode or portal mode all like these
other mode these other games
battlefield
portal is like they're taking like three
or four battlefield games combining it
at all choosing like you could have four
troopers versus like
50 old world war two guys he got machine
guns versus like muskets can the 50 beat
the four type like so much insanity that
people can make and they can set up like
rules of like great red light green
light i've seen them do that online like
they're squid games in battlefield i
mean i saw one thing where people were
trying to make it so i mean like you can
get that creative and destiny hasn't
ever scratched the surface of it not as
always i wish they would i really wish
they would they absolutely should i
think the reason they probably don't is
because their sandbox is really hard to
put into a custom creator so like halo
has it's an arena sandbox so you can
drop weapons on the map as part of the
game mode or you can make it everybody
has energy swords as part of the game i
actually played a custom game yesterday
where we made grapple shot energy sword
and everyone just had unlimited grapple
shot oh my god
that was an entire game it was great
and then you can also make your own maps
once they what's forge comes out which
comes out but um
if it's me
it'll probably be me i gotta imagine but
they'll yeah but we'll see but yeah i'm
uh i'm i've always thought every time i
go to bungee headquarters i'm like you
guys
need to do like moral custom games like
let people make modes because that is
half of the halo game modes were
discovered because players made them in
fact that was like a player game mode
that then they added into the game uh
canonically so like they just need to do
it man it's a great idea yep great well
sir scarole thank you for joining us we
have the meatiest of all twabs i think
ever 6 000 words and 18 pages per cosmos
tweets we have a lot to discuss tonight
so we may as well get cracking on it i
would get it say it's probably a pretty
good idea
basically my goal in this one and i will
put timestamp in there i'm trying to
keep track of it for everybody so if
you're watching this later on timestamps
will be there if you want to hit certain
sections see what we think about it i'm
going to try and break this up as we can
i don't know how long this thing is
going to take so timestamps will be
crucial but we will do our best
i already read this thing out on my
youtube or on twitch streaming and then
put it up on youtube mine was 50 minutes
i saw tassies was 36. um i think cool
guy on fallout was 52 minutes like this
is not a short thing so just get
comfortable go for a walk with your dog
do some chores whatever you got to do
you're going to have to get comfortable
let's get it
so first thing we've got here is going
to be basically
we're going to jump deep into the
sandbox it's all about abilities that
we're going into uh they do a quick you
know before they dive into it they're
just going to give a run down of what
we're going to cover on the 30th
anniversary december 7th um they're
going to basically drop the 30th
anniversary patch which is going to have
the content that we're getting we
actually saw it was the dares of
eternity which is the six player
activity uh tom farnsworth tweeted that
one that looks like it's got the
um
the nine emblems symbols on it so i'm
very intrigued to see what that's all
about we also get the dungeon gal horn
catalyst exotic all that fun stuff bunch
of ornaments that'll be coming but also
as of last weekend now this week huge
changes to the game and this is probably
some of the biggest ones we've seen they
said in game there's still plenty of to
do between seasonal challenges but right
now we are in pretty quiet time until it
drops uh next thursday is thanksgiving
so the 12 will be very light next week
that's why this thing is probably the
biggest one we've ever seen
so first thing is kevin giannis
jumps in to
say he wants to kind of give a overview
and they need to let eric smith and mike
humboldt go a little deeper on some of
the details
but we've got um
earlier this year he said we heard
overwhelming feedback that the crucible
has been largely dominated by ability
usage and you'll notice that as a trend
through almost this entire thing that
ability usage in crucible is basically
too much like people see it too often
they're trying to get back into gun play
shout out real quick to xenthos the 999
super chat first time catching y'all
live i usually listen to spotify thanks
for the great content you are welcome
glad to see you got one of these live um
at its core destiny is game about space
magic so any adjustments to our
abilities must be made with care we
believe the changes we have made will
keep the heart of what destiny abilities
it fun intact while shaving down some of
the excessive cases we've seen out there
i said they feel it's important to
reinforce here that it's part of
destiny's strength is that it's a live
game and we're able to iterate and
improve on the game as it goes
so basically they're trying to build on
the foundations of this thing but the
big theme you'll notice from a lot of
this stuff minus some other tweaks and
balance things is they're trying to push
away from abilities
mostly in pvp and that's the other nice
thing i will say kind of up front is
they did a huge separation and you'll
see it a lot between pvp and pve
and i just kind of wanted to get your
guys thoughts on this before we go
nitty-gritty of what your like kind of
top thoughts were if you thought these
were positive or negative changes and
also you know i think we can kind of put
to rest these splitting of sandboxes now
as well so scaro um where you at so far
just like high level view on this are
you excited with what you see is there
any are you like
in between are you like negative nancy
where you at very excited uh there's
nothing i hate more than you know
one shot bs like getting
smacked in the face by shoulder charge
randomly or any of these things shatter
dive oh my goodness any anything like
that so anytime we're going more towards
a you know a more gun focused game
that's a big plus for me
uh so i'm very much liking this idea
travis what about you
yeah i'm sort of in the same boat
i i still
think part of what makes destiny special
is the the abilities that you have but i
think they
sometimes they can go from being like
strategic to just being like toxic and
and that's like they become a crutch
where people it's just leaning on it and
that's all how many titans have you seen
that only get you know shoulder charge
melee kills how many hunters have you
seen that only ever succeed if they're
using shatter dive how many warlocks
have you seen succeeded anything you
know
there are certain things that should be
a one shot like i've always thought if
you can stick a grenade on someone it
should be a one shot although
the amount of
kind of assist that it gave you or would
hold on somebody and destiny one was
definitely way too much it like took no
skill because like hey we're talking
about halo halo has a one one hit kill
grenade but you get no assist you have
to aim perfectly with that plasma
grenade so um you know something like
that i think would be pretty good but
yeah you definitely shouldn't be able to
one shot somebody with shatter dive
that's insane or or as i see in trials
uh one shot three people using shatter
dive
yeah that's correct yeah that's that's a
lot of things what about you just quick
overview of this one if you got a chance
to read it yeah yeah i love the
philosophy change i mean i think that's
i think for people who are outside
looking in on destiny that was always
their issue like they were just like hey
i wanted to be more gun play focused and
it's way too much ability spam and that
would kind of turn some of the hardcore
balance guys off so yeah this is this is
good and now i just wanted to see as we
get deeper how far they go because my my
initial reaction was okay this is good
but i just wanted to make sure they
don't go into like vanilla d2 mode
remember with an led to where you just
was like taking forever anything to
charge kind of thing but as we as i read
i'm very more excited so i can't wait
till for us to get into it but this is a
great philosophy change what about you
yeah i mean me
overall positive changes there are a
couple questions that i've had and i
kind of want to see how a couple things
play out but overall i like where
they're going i like what they're doing
a lot of the biggest thing for me is
that split pve versus pvp is
substantially listed
all over the place that like and that
was my first worry is like what you said
are we gonna go back to d1 vanilla with
like double primaries and abilities that
are up like every hour and it's just
like i don't want that again because as
you guys have said the magic of the game
does come from your abilities and pve
should be the fun
power fantasy if you can separate them
we've always said and finally this is
the most substantial level this i've
seen so that was probably my biggest
takeaway is these sandboxers are
starting to get separated and i think it
had to happen otherwise they were really
gonna just start to kind of lose out on
some fun that we could have but one of
the things they mentioned is that the
team touched almost every piece of
abilities content with this release and
they said this will be our biggest
balance patch ever and that's huge and
we'll scroll through and you guys will
see how long it is but they didn't miss
much in this as we go through everything
so we definitely will have to
try and cover as much as we can i'll try
not to dwell too long on anything but
there's some interesting ones we'll have
to touch on so
um first thing is the winds of change
so this one will kind of give you guys
an overview because this actually goes
into some of their thoughts on all of
this in the 30th anniversary we've
changed the way ability cooldowns work
and this is kind of important for a lot
of things including pvp up until now
cooldowns across individual ability
types grenade melee super have generally
been identical between all abilities for
example all the grenades in destiny 2
share the same cooldown i said this
shared cooldown mean that all grenades
had to have roughly the same power the
nice thing is now they've got like you
know so many adjustment knobs that they
can tune everywhere they can separate
different grenades more powerful faster
slower all of these things change and
they give a very specific example of a
flux grenade versus a firebolt grenade a
flux grenade which is the hunter one
that you can throw
is going to have the base cool down
increased from 82 seconds to
182 seconds it's gonna go from like a
minute and twenty to three minutes long
now the increased attached detonation
damage to 250 it will be a one shot kill
in pvp and we have not had that in a
while they increased the damage to pve
combatants by 15
on top of the base increase they but
they removed the projectile tracking so
it is just like what you guys were
talking about the halo grenade if you
can stick it there is no assist you got
to stick it very accurately uh they
added a small amount of aim assist on
the throw smidge but it's still not
gonna have any tracking or curving to it
and they increase the throw speed by 117
percent basically it's a rocket out of
your fist it seems like and it sticks to
all surfaces so you've got a huge change
in a grenade that's now three times
longer it's a one-shot kill
it's only for hunters which we'll change
later which they talk about versus take
a firebolt grenade reduce base damage
cooldown from 82 to 64 seconds now you
get it in base of a minute reduce the
damage per bolt from 90 to 65 and they
increase the damage versus pv combatants
like a lot of things in pv are getting
buffed like that's just going to be a
common theme but you got one grenade
getting
more than twice as long of the cooldown
another one coming down by about 20
that's just two grenades so it's like
when you guys got to this point do you
see anything major between these two
that's exciting or like i mean this is
the level of detail that they're gonna
get into so what do you guys think
i think one thing that they did that was
that's really good they increased the
damage that a flux grenade does but not
enough to kill a super so most supers
get like 60 damage resistance so 250
isn't going to kill it
which is good like there's no if you
know popping a hammer titan getting
stuck by a grenade i would be furious if
i died so
um i think that's a that's a nice little
bit of foresight that they did there but
i i mean yeah i think it's uh i think
it's cool i'm i'm kind of excited for it
maybe some uh fireball uh top tree dom
blade uh builds potentially i know
people like their solar grenades but
i'd be very interested to see what this
sort of thing if you went like tier 10
discipline and some other stuff that
seems like it's going to be a frequent
grenade that you'll be able to throw but
well top tree as well gives you uh
i think grenades if you get kills in the
air or it gives you melee which then
gives you grenades or something i've
heard that circular chain of crazy did
something like that yeah
cog what about you on the warlock action
there any excitement for the fire bolt
or where are you where you at
you are muted i think
oh cause the cars are going by sorry
boom yeah like i think for me it was
like
this started the hinting of tiering
and to me what they're looking at as
potent and i kind of like it i kind of
like okay you're looking at certain
builds and you're saying okay we're
going to make this powerful we're going
to separate it from pve so the pve
experience does not get affected for the
most part and not made on fun which was
their problem before but i like this
idea of looking at every class every
ability and saying okay you're kind of
here on the on the t as far as potency
we can slow your cool down on certain
things right and then this one maybe
okay you're not as powerful but maybe we
give you a little bit more uptime and
and that's the kind of thing i'm liking
so
get excited y'all i don't know if i get
gas like this is we're getting into a a
true separation and balancing traffic
where we at how you feeling
yeah i think the main thing i took away
from this paragraph was less about like
the specifics of what they told us about
the grenades and more about them
conveying their philosophy that like
things are going to be different now not
only is pvp and pve going to be sort of
separated which should have happened a
long time ago frankly because that's
always been just a give and take where
the pvp community is pissed off at the
pve players because their new subclass
ruined pvp
pve players are mad when the pvp
community forces you know the band
hammer to come down or the nerf hammer
and then and then they're like oh man
now i'm not as good in pve so it
definitely needed to happen regardless
um i'm glad that that it's happening and
i hope they just i hope they just go all
in and make it completely separate the
only problem that they'll have there is
having two very separate feeling
experiences in pvp and pve can be a bit
difficult to manage you know when you're
like used to playing one way in pve and
then you go to pvp and you're like
nothing feels like it works here my
powers are so slow everything
it can just make the game mode feel a
little
less exciting which we'll have to see
you know if it gets to that point kind
of wish we had loadouts if they ever if
they ever went that far being able to
switch loadouts would be beneficial they
should be at this point because at this
point your pvp loadout is going to make
absolutely no sense in pve pretty
quickly
um so we'll see that but the idea of
tiering and all that i think is a great
idea um should have existed a long time
that sort of trade-off of how quickly
you uh how quickly you get your ability
versus how how good it is i think is is
great there'll be people who
you know are more ability heavy that
maybe choose worse powers just so they
can rely on them more and that sort of
thing which i think is is really a great
idea um but yeah i'm hoping that the
examples that they gave were just sort
of like a taste of things to come not
the exact because obviously like titans
also have a sticky grenade that can use
some love i think warlocks do too so
you know hopefully it's not just those
examples yeah and the philosophy gets me
very excited yeah they even said at one
point somewhere in this giant novel of
an article um they did mention that the
patch notes are insanely long so we
didn't put everything in here uh just
because they said that would be a bore
some people would love to read through
twice as long but i was like think teddy
kept it kept it where it would be yeah
so uh they said these kinds of varied
cooldowns and power output should make
the game feel more dynamic and give more
depth to build crafting which is what
they're leaning into to make build
crafting around cooldowns easier you'll
now be able to see the base cool down
time of your abilities when selecting
them on the subclass screen which is a
brand new thing so if you go to the
subclass screen you choose chain
lightning for your melee you can see the
base cool down to minute 30. uh you can
also see your strength and just a
reminder the base cooldown is based off
of tier three on a stat
so that's what the base so if you're on
tier three your base is going to match
that if you manage to get underneath
that which is really hard to do
accidentally but if you do manage to get
underneath that you will be under what
they consider the base but that's
something that doesn't happen unless you
actually try to
uh they said one of our design goals
this year was to reduce the amount of
ability spam and crucible as we
discussed and put the focus back on
gameplay
and they said to this end we've made the
ability cooldown times longer on average
than they were before we don't want the
pve experience to suffer for the sake of
pvp balance though which is i read that
and i was just insanely excited like
that was the biggest
biggest thing for me to read i know so
we've tried to compensate where possible
for example we've increased all grenade
damage versus pve combatants by 15 or
more and they said this should make
their grenades feel
bigger and more powerful moments than
they do in the game
so i'll be curious to see how that i
mean 15 versus a longer timer kind of a
back and forth um it's one of those
things where got to get our hands on it
in pvd pvp or pve i should say to see if
actually like i wish it was up a little
more frequently but they are trying to
make the difference of it hitting harder
so we'll just have to see how it goes
i think that'll be really good um so for
instance when solo athie on the strat is
middle tree
solar titan because you can do some
pretty insane grenade damage stacking
and i think that 15 on that uh you'll
still because a lot of that doesn't
really matter about your cool your base
cooldown it's a lot of using like the uh
the
heart of inmost lights uh and a couple
other uh perks on the subclass to get
your grenades back like instantly um
also you get your grenades back
instantly atheon now that's what that's
what it is and um
so i think that'll be pretty nuts for
encounters like that so yeah absolutely
you guys can't see this one if you're
listening to audio but the cat
definitely just walked by scarole so yep
giant tail just goes
right across the face i like that tail
ability cool down
so one of the other big ones they
mentioned is
super generation changes and especially
for pvp so they said super energy gain
has been almost entirely passive and
this is going to be a big thing for pvp
mostly uh your analytics that dictates
how quickly your super generates with
few other elements like orbs power armor
weapon perks yada yada
this system works well for the a long
time but has issues that have grown more
obvious as the game has involved with
skill and basically it's made a lot of
people play very passively at high level
pvp because
if you're just waiting on a timer you
want to be alive as long as possible so
your option is usually to play very
passively stay behind cover and then
have those one-off moments where you go
off and kill a whole team
so they said to get closer to the goal
they're making some big changes so in
pve super uptime should be relatively
unchanged for the live game if not
slightly higher so that's actually a
good thing pv still not getting hit
keeping them separate i said everybody
should get at least one super in a 6v6
match that goes to the score or time
limit as long as they engage in regular
combat if you're getting a lot of kills
you might get two that's a thing
supers should be less frequent in 3v3
modes than in the live game where two
supers per match is a fairly regular
occurrence and again that goes back to
the passive you may play trials and get
stomped but at high level trials they're
very passive unless that objective like
last week was involved and then
generally you're going to have a tail
walk in front of your face now
no you're good you're good so they said
these modes are about expressing player
skill and we want that skill to be
primarily about team coordination
positioning intelligent use of your
abilities and first and foremost gunplay
which is what a lot of people for pvp
want gunplay to be the focus while
there's absolute skill in outmaneuvering
active supers or playing around super
uptime supers in general are
purposefully designed to be accessible
power fantasies for all players and that
inherently creates asymmetry that we
need to account for
primary weapons should have a noticeable
benefit in super energy regeneration so
they said with this new system we are
scaling energy gains up and down
granularly based on the source of damage
both outgoing and incoming
so outgoing primary weapon damage has a
significantly higher return of super
energy per damage point than the any
other damage type so i wanted to stop
there because that is actually kind of a
huge shift when it comes to pvp
specifically what do you guys think on
that one travis you're kind of bobbing
your head were you out on where are you
at on this where you feeling your pvp
world going
yeah um i mean this has been like a
kind of elephant in the room in pvp like
even in the destiny one days like in
trials where it's like all right
everybody's i know everybody's gonna get
their super at the same time it's not
even just in trials even a normal like
match made crucible matches or iron
banner or whatever first time you hear
somebody pop off a super you're like oh
god there's going to be like nine supers
all back to back i'm gonna get killed
like four times and spawn and it's just
gonna be really toxic and then after all
of the dust settles then it's gonna go
back to
it kind of being like a regular game and
it just uh it sort of
it me it means that you have to perform
extra well in the first half of the
match before that craziness hits to kind
of build momentum and get your super
first and it's kind of a race to get
your super first um so i really like
that they're they're doing this i do
think you should still get your super
every match like it should happen but i
think based on the super that you have
it taking longer or or shorter amount of
time depending on what type of super it
is totally makes sense to me but i hate
the impending oh but it's the fourth
round of trials like
everybody's going to get super it's kind
of like heavy round except for way more
toxic and then every round after becomes
about like managing who has their super
it's like all right well
they've got two supers so let's try to
bait them and make them use one and
there's it's just it affects so much
that i feel like that if they can if
they can do something to minimize its
impact or at least uh kind of get it out
at different times depending on the
super that would be amazing but uh i
have i have my
doubts that they can actually do that
because there's always a meta
there's always like two or three supers
that everyone uses and it'll essentially
just be the exact same thing except for
the one weird guy who has a super that
he either gets way earlier or way later
and i could just see it not really
fixing a lot you know what i mean um and
then also it'll kind of depend on how
optimized you are the other thing that i
worry about is
how much is my intellect really going to
matter in this meta it sounds like
impact because intellect is no longer
time-based super
farmers becoming more and more useless
yeah yeah it could also be a multiplier
on you know if you get x amount of
that's super good they'll do i think
that's what i think they'll do i think
if like you have higher intellect every
time you get shot out or do damage
you'll get more of percentage but i have
a feeling the way that they're talking
about it the importance of intellect is
really going to be minimized because i
just don't see it because then the
solution would be easy right everyone
would have a hundred ends and it would
just it would bring us back to the exact
same problem we have now so i think no
matter what happens at least in pvp your
uh your attributes are gonna get nerfed
a little bit um specifically the
intellect one so i have my concerns
about it i think it's going to take a
while to get this fixed even if it if it
can't even be fixed but i'm glad they're
addressing it because at least in pvp
it's just sucked for a really long time
that whole super problem so
yeah
one thing i'm worried about uh bungie
has a history of forgetting to make sure
that non-player things don't count so
like telesto bolt's uh environmental
things stasis crystals uh titan
barricade so i'm worried that you can
just like unload and do italian
barricade and have your super you know i
doubt that's the case but there's always
a change you can doubt it but the way
things have been going things keep
getting missed like we've you know
they've they've given us given us some
good stories and buggy seasons so that's
the first thing i'm doing bring telesto
in shoot my own telesco bolts insta
super you know like it's like
i mean so i'd
do that every round that's going to
stack up pretty quick yeah so i don't
it's
just a slight concern hopefully i didn't
give anyone any ideas but
uh you definitely did yeah they're
shooting
but
yeah we'll see we'll see
love it love it love it love it love it
this is great um
with high level play especially you know
you play trials and i just remember
dudes in the back of the map just deep
chilling
waiting for that ability to go up bro
and i'm just like come on man you know
what i'm saying so it's like this is
great you know engagement
you know what i'm saying like yo come on
bro like
we i love the rewarding of engagement
and non-passive play and what i like is
also skilled players are gonna benefit
skilled players that are actively
engaging and getting their kills off and
stuff like that you know should benefit
and i feel that that's how it should be
you know i mean so this is this is a
great change because the uniformity of
everyone having their super at the same
time is kind of what used to annoy me
like what travis said they're always
that point of the match where you're
like in the 6v6 or 343. all right guys
this is the round all right everybody
everybody's super up yeah everybody and
then what would be so frustrating you
you take so long to get it and then when
you finally get it to get killed by
someone else's supers you really don't
get the the efficiency of utilization of
the super and this is this is good stuff
i was shocked by this i was like okay
okay now granted to scarole's point we
gotta watch out with the doing damage to
oneself and to see how dudes are gonna
try to finesse that if possible you know
that's a cute word exactly also in like
pve if you have a like an overload
champion you just sit there and shoot
them endlessly like does that yeah
right so i don't know yeah yeah we got
we got some trade off with with incoming
damage that that's the only thing we're
going to watch but yeah what you got man
what was your thoughts when you and this
kind of came across your tongue i mean
it definitely feels like a big shift
because you do take a point to where
everybody cares about the cooldown timer
yeah you'll get some when you get a kill
but it's like it says the incoming and
outgoing damage so i think it gives
it gives more people an opportunity even
if they're getting stomped on
to get theirs in a little bit more of a
quicker fashion as well because the idea
of if you can put some damage in or
you're getting the assists half the time
or whatever it may be
or you're just getting destroyed
whatever it is you have a better chance
at getting some of those things up and
then they break it into tears which
we'll get into in a second but the idea
just the fact that it's more based
around the damage and i think it's more
the idea if it is executed correctly
outside of everything you guys have
worries about hopefully they've thought
of that if not you have three months
guys figure it out
yes please figured out before which
queen at least that's the important one
but
if they can figure that out then it does
really
like promote the use of those primary
guns it does make me wonder about
specials though like where they await
special kills like our sniper is not
going to be as effective when it comes
to
getting that super up if you can get two
quick picks or anything but you don't
get as much you know super out of it is
more advantageous to use a scout and get
those long range picks because you'll
get your super energy faster i don't
know if that will happen damage done
right now yeah that's what i that's what
i think as well
yeah so like you know what damn it a
sniper shot does like 150 damage or
whatever yeah you get 150 damage but i'm
also kind of worried about though on
that on the flip side of that if you
have a guy that's just hitting bodies
and you're not team sean are you just
giving the other team super
like yeah that's the other thing i i was
wondering like also because you get
super for taking damage so yeah if i'm
in pve and i'm trying to get my super
back it actually benefits me to shoot a
guy while also taking as much damage as
possible without dying so i kind of like
want to stay in there or hit me a couple
times
if somebody could just shoulder charge
me real quick
that'd be great that would be great
the primary weapon focus because i think
a previous 12 we even start we started
to see
them trying to reward primary play in
pve
by like getting exotic ammo drops where
was it scavengers or whatever it was or
um yeah that's scary the one that drops
the brick in the in the head
ammo finder and i was like oh it
increases when you use the primary and
you see this continued primary focus so
that part about it i like because let's
be real you know in pvp you know you're
using that special a lot for the one-hit
kill potential you know saying stuff
like that so it's good to see primary
get a little bit of push out but we do
got to see how it's balanced yeah
that being said
uh supers they have separated them into
cool down tiers uh and they affect both
passive regeneration as well as the
damage based regeneration so you will
have both passive and damage based but
there is going to be a tier system to
this and they said they've taken account
general potency of the subclass kits
where possible for example
an example later on we'll discuss
shatter dive and changes we're making
which will in fact impact how effective
the revenant hunter is in the neutral
game it's also important to
stress that this is the first iteration
of the system where any given super will
fall into uh recharge rate tiers will
change over time as they continue tuning
one very specific example they live down
below so they have the fastest
regeneration is tier five slowest
regeneration is tier one so i'm going to
list these things off fastest
regeneration is well of radiance that is
the only tier five right now i am going
to just like skip to the bottom and then
we'll say win void 3.0 launches in
february so you get about a three month
wait on this one ward of dawn being is
it's going to have the aspect and
fragment thing going on ward of dawn
will be bumped up to a tier five so
those two supports come which queen will
be sitting in tier five at least those
two tier four
blade barrage and silence and squall
those are the only two for tier four
both hunters tier three shadow shot
burning maul arc staff nova bomb and
thunder crash
some of those are singles some of those
are you know kind of intermixed in
between tier two getting on the slower
end now golden gun chaos reach novel
warp storm trance daybreak and sentinel
shield and the slowest of all of them is
tier one you've got spectroblades
winter's wrath and then fist of havoc
hammer of soul and glacial quake
so we'll say for you guys i was just
going to say like any outliers where do
you guys think these fall any bad
choices any good choices
you must see that
thunder crash is what a tier three yes
it's dead in the middle
yeah actually that sounds about right i
was gonna say i was gonna get you with
that one but
i was just gonna say titans have three
of them at tier one and i'm just like
really have so many
roaming supers yeah okay glacial quake
should not be a tier one that oh
they talked about it
yeah that's right yeah
for pvp glacial quake no bueno fist of
havoc hammer of soul i get those sure
spectral blades yup winter's wrath
insanely powerful as well those i get i
was just like of the roamers i was just
like glacial quick can that at least be
tier two it does it's not great sandal
shield isn't that great either but the
way i'm looking at it is the this is
where they want them to be right right
ideally these tier ones are all really
good roaming supers and you only get
them every once in a while but now that
they're making them
making you wait longer before you get
them they can afford to make them a
little better so they'll probably buff
sentinel shield and uh hopefully glacial
quake um in pvp
with this rollout but yeah right now
obviously like who the heck is gonna use
sentinel shield if it has the longest
wait time and it's not very good to
begin with well to play devil's advocate
there central sentinel shield can duel
any super in the entire game oh the
middle tree middletree is is like the
best super dueling
um
what i what i was thinking is like well
of radiance i think this screams is
getting a nerf the fact that it's so
fast especially in pve that's crazy
i guess it depends like what the
separation between the tiers is i i'm
kind of going in like maybe like a 15
second
base or something no uh separation but
well of radiance is like still one of
the most busted pve supers and it's so
weird that they gave it its own tear if
they're not nerfing it it's definitely
coming the only thing
well the only thing i can think is also
you've got ward of done and they're the
only two support supers they're not
offensive so that you're only two
support supers and they're okay with
more of the support side especially in
both pvp or pve because you're not just
clearing a room you're giving you damage
but you've still got to kill stuff with
your weapons so then they're benefiting
the weapon damage and that promotion
versus say
because i'll go in right now because
i'll go bottom tree because i've been
running just the nightfalls this week
the double drops just on matchmade if i
got nothing to do drops in there are
crazy by the way i'll get like
five cores two prisms in one nightfall
on hero go do those if you need a few um
but for
bottom tree hammers
when the waves of all the adds come out
on hollowed lair i'll literally just sit
on one side of the stairs and i can
clear an entire wave by myself
on that one so that one always feels
really good as opposed to something like
bubble when i'm just like gonna sit in
the back and shoot all the guys yeah if
that one comes up quicker that's
probably okay especially as now
especially for the bubble i would say
more under a boss like they want you
even in resilience even more so to get
the benefit out of those you got to kind
of lean a little more into the stats i
don't know as they're the only two
support i kind of get it i guess we'll
see if it's like abused horribly which
it likely will be but we'll have to see
uh most of it seems to make sense like
the tier fours blade barrage that's a
one-off
but that one has like personally more
spread than say a thunder crash
the thunder surprise thunder crash was
was at three but
yeah uh silence and squall that one
not the best super in the world more of
just kind of area effect um golden gun
at tier two chaos reached a tier two
nova warp is actually getting a buff
which is why that one's probably going
to change daybreak signal shield a lot
of these seem not too bad
burning maul just better get a buff
sometime soon burning ball is just trash
most of the time so that one just needs
a little love god what about you in the
warlocks any any outliers you think
these are reasonable for you where are
you at i think they're mostly reasonable
i think i was like um scarra was like
all right well the reason it's getting
that fast interesting maybe to promote
pvp play
but um it's interesting because i was
looking at
storm trance
chaos reaching nova warp all in the same
kind of spot and i just thought that was
interesting knowing what we get is a
roman super star and storm trance as
well
it's interesting the way they grouped
all of them together you know say kind
of thing but i'm not going to say like
right now i'm like
i'm pissed off or anything like that
there's anything that looks super
egregious to me right now i'm just like
yo this look crazy i just got to wait
and see i got to see how it plays out
plus we do know another reason i don't
want to go too crazy because of void 3.0
i want to see how the fragments and
stuff is going to play out because a lot
of stuff these are just like bass lines
as far as i'm concerned and i think a
lot of stuff can really affect that once
we start playing around with those
aspects and stuff so you know the jury's
still out but it is interesting yep
uh but yeah i mean as i said ward of
dawn with the void 3.0 is gonna bump
that specific super up to tier five so
when void 3.0 com comes in this whole
list may get a big shift depending on
where everything's falls at least
specifically the void ones we'll have to
see where that stuff lands
i'm super interested how they do that by
the way because like you know with the
aspect of fragment we have one super
with all of those so how are they gonna
are they gonna keep all three variations
are they gonna make each of the
variations like maybe different
fragments
um or whatever i mean my hope would be
because right now you just have like on
the stasis you've got your grenade your
melee your super but you just would have
dropped down super options would be a
hope is there a drop down super for
stasis no but but it has a node for the
super right
like it has
like a place it's not a node but but
they could very i could i i always
wondered this because luke smith said at
the very beginning like oh if we made
the light subclasses we'd have to choose
a super and i'm like why like there's
plenty of room on the screen yeah well
then later on they said that that wasn't
going to be a thing so he did yeah
i wondered why that was ever even like a
thing because that it seems to me like
pretty obvious like you you have a drop
down super and then only certain aspects
and fragments can be equipped if they
work with that suit oh yeah
it seems kind of easy yeah some will get
grayed out if it doesn't work with like
a throwing hammer or a throwing knife
like you could tweak some certain ways i
could see that yeah i could see that i
could see that
so next thing that we got is going to be
taking it down a notch
uh they said their goals for the pvp
combat sandbox is as follows weapons
they want and this is what they want
it's not where they are and that's what
they clearly state so take that
weapons are the primary way players
engage with combat non-super abilities
accentuate or augment the combat but
should rarely solve an encounter by
themselves abilities have clear
strengths weaknesses and counter play
build crafting is rewarded with the
moment-to-moment combat loop of destiny
they said that's what they want them to
be but they are not there yet in general
ability uptime and crucible is far too
high
so they said they've tuned pve energy
regeneration separately from their base
pve values which they are not changing
so pve p like ability regeneration not
getting touched
pvp
that's where most of these changes that
we're going to list are going to be what
we're talking about
part of it as well they mentioned um
subclass neutral pert uh subclass
neutral game perks they said these perks
have had their ability regeneration
reduced by about 50 in pvp again not pve
we targeted perks that can either
activate out of combat with a single
button press or those that were
returning amounts of ability energy that
were significantly out of band
uh whisper of shards stasis fragment arc
web storm collar warlock rising storm
storm collar warlock ionic trace storm
color warlock electric surge storm color
warlock that would be a pattern that was
like a beating there aftershock striker
titan inertia override strike your titan
benevolent dawn dawn blade warlock
practice makes perfect gunslinger hunter
and dark matter void walker warlock
yeah there's a few warlock changes there
how you feeling [ __ ]
i mean
i mean i think scary
ionic traces i definitely agree with
like i'll be
we knew there was
this is going to come if if the if the
gameplay is about reducing ability spam
and regeneration
all that stuff feeds back when little
traces run to me on the floor to give me
back you know some of my abilities i
knew that you know it was time it was
time so i'm not too crazy it's just
funny to see the storm claw get
lambasted like this but there is truth
to it there is there is some truth to a
lot of this stuff is a cycle of energy
regeneration that they got to control so
i i get it i can't yeah just don't have
to like it but i mean they went after
certain ones you have the ability to
generation of the stormcaller you got
the striker titan with its abilities to
like and also the super which they touch
in a second as well um but yeah i was
like pretty heavy on a couple they also
say super uh subclass in super perks
those perks scale down injury to returns
as you get kills in your super i.e the
first kill gets you a lot of super
energy the more you kill the less you
get back so they eventually kind of have
you know deterioration there no change
has been made to the refund decay
against pve combatants they plastered
that everywhere because if they did they
were going to get questions about
everything so i appreciate it said
everlasting fire with dawn blade warlock
and trample with striker titans both i
cannot believe uh
golden gun six shot isn't on here where
you get more shots the more kills you
get
in pvp that would yeah because that's
how people get like i've seen sevens go
off like the seventh columns with those
yeah i i mean i don't i'm not saying it
needs it but i also wouldn't say that oh
everlasting dom like that's like don
blake's like the worst super in pvp i'm
convinced it's so
not the subclass this the subclass is
fine the super itself is like mid at
best and uh i just
i don't i don't really
i don't think it needs this nerf more
than golden gun but that's just that's
just me but
uh it is you know once again we don't
know how significant the change is i'll
be very interested to see you know what
what it actually is in the game so
we'll see then also with regards to
exotics uh we have the frosties no
longer stacks multiplicatively in pvp
with other generation buffs it is now an
additive scaler harder than most light
ability regeneration scalers to 50 in
pvp controversy hold duration of the
grenade regeneration buff is no longer
random between one and four seconds it's
now a fixed duration uh but it was
typically seen about one second so it's
now kind of going to be a fixed 1.75 so
it's a little longer doomfang pauldrons
reduce super energy gain on activation
um so you get to uh by about fifty
percent shinobu's val reducer grenade
energy gain hits on players by 66 that's
pretty substantial crown of tempest
grenade melee super energy regeneration
scalar buff reduced from seven seconds
down to four and the stag reduce class
ability energy refund on shield break by
fifty percent
none of that touches pve
just so you guys are aware
yeah that that's fair especially i know
my stag locks
oh my god you guys are everywhere pvp
yes
you see those horns peeking out from
yeah
it's like i'm not going it's like here's
a cover
and then here's this like poof it's like
i can see about the third circle just a
little bit
here you go everybody's got their little
ark buddy up here on their little
shoulder
oh yeah that was a build bro i had them
arc snitches on deck and everybody's
stepping inside the little kiddie pool
getting a little damaged with that let's
go baby
i was super toxic i am not even going to
lie to you that's so awful yeah that's
so annoying it's nice when it's on your
team when it's on the other one you're
like kill me now just get it out
but overall i mean again these are not
pve changes so if you want to use your
doomfang pauldrons to have infinite
shield throws uh shout out to new rad
and chat he sent me a video where dude
had a two hour video
of the
super of the doom fang pauldron's super
in like a thrallway just kept chunking
his shield and it lasted for two hours
and i was just like but you can still do
that so just fyi pve is not getting
touched just wanted to say that one so
um armor mods also again if you stack
these things up it can get a little
ridiculous so they're basically chopping
these down by about 50 melee kickstart
grenade kickstart utility kickstart
perpetuation bolstering detonation
focusing strike bomber outreach dynamo
distribution momentum transfer and
impact induction so a lot of those mods
where
you know you use an ability you get
ability energy back you use melee you
get some grenade energy use all of those
are going to be giving you less
in pvp again
are there any of these mods that you
guys crutch heavy on that you have like
builds based around when you're like oh
man that's going to kind of hurt do you
guys have any of these that you think
about what what's up you shaking your
head [ __ ] oh they they out here blowing
up my whole pill
like it's bad for me like all my little
toxicity has been broken i used to run
double bomber i do all type of stuff for
grenade regeneration then use um
what's the what's the stitch exotic
getaway artist i had a flow where my
discipline was so high bro i was always
having it it was bad like welcome to the
gun play [ __ ] welcome to the gun play
listen you know they're not so good guys
gotta gotta overcompensate another error
hey i admit it that was my formula for
subpar pvp play i gotta try to get
better now
oh man uh the only one i see is dynamo a
lot of times people will watch like
double dynamo to yeah
so
that'll be cool yeah i keep wondering if
there's any of these that i'm not paying
attention to with regards to like dodges
because whatever hunters can use to get
their dodges up quicker i know they're
using i just don't know which one of
these is actually that one but
yeah hundred dodge is a whole topic
you guys use any of those filthy bots
titans don't need supers we are the
super bro oh fudge i don't need it
over there with like confused eyes he's
like
because if they're nerfing the super and
they're nerfing the ability then you're
just the same with a different jump
but i can still melee
[Laughter]
it's not a one-hit kill anymore
no i i honestly i never really abused
any of the um any of the ability stuff i
i used it when i could but to be honest
most of the titan abilities aren't great
like
well we don't have any grenades i mean
so one example that i've heard for say
trials is sight and ramparts 100
resilience and double utility to have
that wall that shoot through wall up
like
all the time
like that's the type of stuff i've seen
same thing i'll be happy to use that in
pve really sightings oh and pvp oh
saturn's ramp oh yeah i see what you're
saying for that thing yeah yeah yeah and
uh i think a lot of that a lot of titans
crutch um
suppressor nades as well so
any of these that affect
grenade regeneration well effectively
yeah i i
i've always i'm sort of wondering where
uh the
where that grenade is going to sit in
terms of the the timer because they
haven't told us what the what the timer
differences are going to be for that one
i'm wondering where that one sits
because you almost never see people use
it so i wonder if they'll give it like a
shorter cooldown that it ought to have
it could be pretty abusive dude
that's like the highest like skill
sealing grenade in the game but when you
get people that are banking that
stuff it's just like
you shut down a super with a little
grenade you're like
if there's if there's any ability i have
abused it's that one so i'll be
interested to see where that goes but i
but that said i don't do anything today
to like make sure i get it back quicker
because i kind of don't have to like you
get it you get it back quick enough as
it is so if they if they nerf that i'll
be interested to see uh how it changes
things but yeah i haven't used site and
ramparts in a really long time that that
i had it i used it for like a month and
i was really on it but i've just been
using antaeus ward recently just like
i've been killing hunters with their own
knives dude it's such a great feeling
so
messing with people with the off
metaphon always a good time yeah
the next thing we've got a change on is
stasis crystals
to no surprise thank god anybody anybody
been waiting on this one it's gonna be
it's been a minute are they taking it
out of the game
the worst part of the crystals is how
big and annoying they are you can't see
anything behind them i hate construction
and they talk about that too that was
crazy so stasis crystals do a lot
as you just said on top of freezing
players when they're created they also
block line of sight block movement and
act as explosive barrels uh it's uh it's
all a bit too much before pvp with this
release stasis crystals will now slow
players instead of freezing them and
also do much less damage to players when
they detonate so basically what they're
doing to stasis crystals is as follows
while forming stasis crystals stasis
while forming stasis crystals now slow
nearby players instead of freezing them
they will still freeze in pve so keep
that in mind
uh increase slow slash freeze radius by
about 0.75 meters reduce crystal
detonation damage versus players by
about 55 percent pour one out for
shatter dive we'll get to that in a
second
increased crystal detonation damage
versus pve combatants by 60 percent
and increased crystal detonation radius
by two meters as well so you will get
slowed and hurt from a little farther
but it's not gonna kill you it's the
biggest thing
uh i have to read this into the um
i'm gonna come back to the dodge in a
second because revenant ties a little
bit more into the cesar stuff
so they said you guessed it the stasis
crystal changes detail earlier mean that
hunter's revenant shatter dive will now
almost never kill a full health guardian
they said if they're using whisper of
fissures touch of winter and the target
is at the very center of all six
crystals technically you can kill them
but they said it's extremely rare so
shatter dive is much less lethal versus
players due to the stasis crystal
damages but they did make it much more
lethal versus combatants due to stasis
crystal changes and they increased the
shatter damage versus frozen pv
combatants by a hundred percent
doubled it so if you actually use that
thing in pvp now it's definitely going
to be hitting pretty hard and they also
increase the aspect
uh pve sorry they increase the aspect
slots on grim harvest by one more
so
yeah revenants didn't have too much
happen but yeah shatter dive and pvp
basically they took out outside and shot
it i think
pretty close good i mean is there
anything i missed there
about
what is that movie uh collateral well
tom cruise does that all time
it's about time
i don't yeah nobody's nobody's set we
don't have hunters right now so nobody
is sad about this well they already made
it they already nerfed it for titans
remember for a while titans were sliding
through their crystals and that was like
the meta but yeah they made that
subclass so bad that nobody uses it for
titans anyway so i felt like i lost it
and hunter's got to keep it yeah so now
i'm like good i'm glad they all nobody's
going to have it because that was my
move for a long time when when back when
you know stasis was was out there being
as toxic as hell
but yeah this is so long overdue only
took a year who's ready for final shape
so we can do it again yes
let's go
yeah when do you think we're gonna get
that green subclass in um what is it
lightfall
oh all yeah final shapes after that i
forgot yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
i think we might get it in between oh
do you think they would put that in a
season
they wanted to hype it up you know
they're like kings fall returning and
you get it
okay the only way we're getting the
green sub and i say green whatever the
next color it is green black who knows
purple
yeah whatever um
is if we have either a season of the
drifter or a season of the worthy on
deck
and they're like we got to do something
to make this season better
we're going to give them a new subclass
other than that i don't see that until a
expansion because it's also possible
that they're lying to us about it not
being the witch queen because there were
so many credible
leaks about that so many of them i mean
that would be such a big marketing thing
though yeah yeah but this is bungie not
activision if it was activision
bungie bungie has always said we're not
afraid to lose sales so that we can keep
things a surprise and they did it with
dreaming city
i mean it is lose sales they killed in
the marketing yep
that's a good point
they did that but but they didn't they
did keep secrets they don't tell certain
things about the game no and that's fair
but i was like
i don't know that's just one of those i
think by now we would be hearing
yeah
right i i hope you're right i just want
to put that out there if they can pull
off a secret like that
oh yeah yeah of course
can we at least agree that there's going
to be three elements in the kinetic slot
oh yes i mean yeah it feels like it like
they've they've set that up they
basically telegraphed it
and we also know that it would be really
weird if
if the lightness light and dark saga
ended and they were still deploying new
elements it just seems a little
a little off to me i can see them taking
the next year to get all the light bulbs
the pandemic has changed some plans i'm
sure but still yeah possibly yeah you
could be right about that and also i
guess you've made the same argument
about there's no way that they would
introduce a new
enemy type yes
the darkness at the last year and i i
think i made the exact opposite argument
i'm making now where i'm like oh well
destiny's going to continue destiny 2
even is going to continue
the darkness and light saga so they're
actually building on something um
so yeah
maybe maybe i'm wrong but i i i still
don't know if i fully believe that that
i i don't take them at their words
not in the game because everybody is
just taking them sports it's in the game
the only reason that those rumors
stopped is because somebody said at
bungie that it's not in the game that's
the only thing yeah i think it's a lot
of it is is fluid too you know they may
have internal plans that they may have
initially said hey we wanted to have
that ready for which queen but i think
usually with the the subclasses and
stuff like that they kind of use it as
like a bullet point for expansion and
marketing when you're getting ready to
sell it like oh
i think they wanted to and they flat
said they couldn't and also i think at
some point they had to make a shift from
creating something brand new during
working at home times versus fixing
subclass 3.0 and everything else that
we've got to get the aspects and
fragments in there every yeah with
everything that it seems to be to be
doing with far basically what we're
learning this with this swab is they've
been able to
behind the hood separate pve and pvp and
i think that's probably been more of an
undertaking than maybe we think and
yeah other things may have been pushed
down that little bulletin board you know
so to speak of what they have for the
future
rather than fix the light subclasses
first then start introducing new ones
absolutely that's always bothered me is
that it just feels so unequal now like
every season you're getting new
fragments yeah the stasis subclasses
that nobody uses
the titans don't use them anymore uh so
it's just that field
i'm glad i'm facing that i will be
curious as that
as that has been one of the things for
stasis that has been
kind of a little nugget every season
we're gonna get void 3.0 with the witch
queen and we know that's going to give
us obviously the shift to the aspects
and the fragments but are they gonna
like
dump everything into that season for
void altogether or are they gonna like
trickle those things out because they
said like the next season after we'll
have solar 3.0 and the one after that's
gonna have arc 3.0 what however that
goes i mean are they going to trickle or
is it just dump dump dump and don't take
that don't clip that out of context
please
four for each in their respective season
and then the last season is gonna get
like a couple for each one
that would make sense
here's your like initial batch maybe
they'll add like one or two the
following season or whatever but i think
one more thing one more thing about them
possibly lying about the new subclass
they've actually done this before
they lied about the subclasses that were
going to be in destiny 2.
and i know that because there were a ton
of leaks because people accidentally
yeah that remember the uh the third
subclass so for titan the hammers and
for
warlocks saw that they got introduced
into
the taking king and then when they were
putting out destiny 2 they were acting
like the subclasses and the taking king
weren't in the game and that it was just
going to be void and arc for the titans
and basically the taken king subclasses
were getting removed but they hid them
in the game using that secret like
mission where you go and talk to the
seed and i was doing the review for that
game and they were like guys you cannot
talk about the subclasses from the
taking king like pretend they're not in
the game and then a whole bunch of
european outlets didn't didn't
acknowledge it
put on all that crap early and everybody
was like oh my god they're in the game
but they did lie about it they said that
that it was not going to be in the game
and then they put it in the game
sequence what if there is no void 3.0
and there's only a new darkness okay
that's so disappointing
well as we have a question in chat from
a celebrity previous guest i did want to
point it out shout out to
tom warren of the verge previous guest
thank you sir uh but it was kind of a
fitting question we'll get to in a
second uh that the
twa basically states the middle tree
subclasses will disappear for xbox game
packs folks who haven't purchased
forsaken but forsaken is going free as
we're literally in the middle of the
subclass talk we'll get to the game past
like
whole discussion that's going to be the
end of this but i wanted to ask you guys
about that subclass piece
as we're literally in the middle of it
how do you guys think that's going to
work now
and then especially it's free and then
then forsaken is going to be gone come
which queen are they just do you have to
buy the forsaken pack for like what do
you guys think is gonna happen there
because
yeah that's not a great look
so this stuff stuff like this has
happened before you're basically going
to have to go to the xbox store and
click
get for free
and add it to your list of entitlements
and then it'll just give it back to you
yeah but if you don't do that it
wouldn't just be there by default but
what about well they're going to have
the forsaken pack though like to be able
to do the raid to be able to do the
dungeon
that's going to be a thing that they're
still selling after forsaken goes free
there's that forsaken pack so i guess
it's getting taken out of what is in
forsaken and put in that pack so now
that's the way of the forsaking campaign
was getting those
getting those right or is the post
campaign i think it's in the dream part
of the raid right
uh i don't i don't yeah you get one of
the seats through the raid but i think
they added a new way to get it that is
like the yeah there were different
scenes yeah blind well was one yeah the
blind well tier three that was one of
them for sure
uh and that would still be there so it's
like are you gonna have to buy the
forsaken pack two good points go get
your blind well tier
three
subclasses yeah how did how did they
word it were they just like the forsaken
campaign will be free because if they
said that they kind of like the lawyer
talks with their way
out of it if that's the case yeah yeah
it was only the campaign yeah the
campaign was going free
okay so yeah if it's just the campaign
going free then yeah the subclasses
would be taken out because that was not
part of the campaign that was like end
game
yeah we're gonna get to that discussion
and we'll sell it separately
i will definitely say yeah tom i don't
like what we think is gonna happen with
this pack but i will definitely say yeah
it's not a great look and
we'll we'll get to that but if it's what
we're guessing
yeah not a fan
all right now i now have a theory for
what the uh the third subclass is going
to be oh my god
stasis
theory now there we go there we go
it's going to be silver
so there it is silver
silver you can only get it by purchasing
it through eververse using silver and
you unlock it and all of your abilities
are like money based you like
quarters of people
wrap them in a whip it's like 100 bills
and yeah it's like an arcade machine
where it's like insert quarter to
do your super heroes you have to pay
every time you use your supervisor
model or you can have your playtime
cards that you can put your code in for
another four hours of playtime for the
subclass
yeah every grenade is is a nickel they
just no insanity said glimmer yeah your
bullets are your glimmer so they're very
expensive every shot counts
when you have the subclass equipped your
character has a top hat and a monocle as
part of their uh part of their outfit
just oh my god so
yes
as a super
what would be closer to darkness than
that
you're out of control you're messy would
you say
yeah
i uh i uh tracked down where they were
the the actual blog post about vaulting
it's just all it says the forsaken
campaign will be available for free for
all players from december 7th until it
enters the dcv in february and then the
four second packs right after that where
it's like uh the exotics and stuff i i
would bet my liver right now that the
supers are going to be part of the
forsaken
for sure right yeah
oh god that hurts that is so old it
should just be free
what isn't there an achievement tied to
getting um
your sub classes
uh like the newer subclasses when i
think forsaken came out
wasn't there an achievement to getting
like all of them
i'm pretty sure it was i mean i would
guess no no i have no idea that's all
that's gonna be interesting just go you
know just go purchase it and you're good
to go
it might be like you you purchase it it
gives you the seeds of light and then
you have to go yeah turn them out
whatever yeah well i guess if the oh
dreaming city's saying yeah you can
still do that yeah yeah or whatever
do you just gleam in eververse
probably yeah you buy from the store
it'll probably be the same thing as the
30th anniversary where it's like on the
director and you can buy it yeah that's
that would be amazing you can buy the
you can buy the season passes with
silver as well so i would imagine that's
done that way yes yep all right we'll
get to the rest of this you already own
destiny destiny should be free it's a
game as a service it should be free a
free game
especially after two years oh that's
yeah the age on it put a pin on this
we'll get to it yes okay get it go move
forward yeah i'm trying
anywho hunters we already covered
shatter dive but this is kind of what i
want to ask you guys about to see what
you guys think
dodge
and this is going to be kind of an
interesting one
in order to meet our goal of less
ability spam and crucible we're reducing
how often hunters can dodge
gambler's dodge is getting hit the
hardest here because it can completely
circumvent melee ability cooldown times
it also completely changes the hunter
silhouette and pvp making it very
powerful
in addition hunter dodges will no longer
break projectile tracking
meaning it's less of a get out of jail
free card when tracking rocket or other
slow moving projectile flying towards
you so no longer breaking projectiles
the marksman's dodge at tier 10 will
have the cooldown increased from 11 to
14 seconds not that big at tier 10 base
cooldown is ch is unchanged so not a big
change to markman's
gamblers dodge tier 10 is up to 18
seconds so seven seconds longer shout
out to my dogs
base cool down duration from 29 seconds
to 38 seconds so they are extending the
dodge i mean it's it's seven seconds
depending on how you're stacking it up
but i wanted to see if you guys think
my honest like playing against hunters
in pvp for me is one of those where i'm
like
yeah you guys dodge a lot it's really
annoying you can go invisible on top of
that you get your melee back like you
get your reloads
it is a frustrating thing to play
against i get it now granted it is their
thing i have a wall so i've always feel
a bit pigeon-holed you guys have a
healing rift or an empowering rift i
have a wall and then they can dodge get
their health blank so again the hundred
dodge for me was always rough but i was
actually gonna ask the titans of
warlocks are just laughing right now
[Laughter]
i'm not my i'm not much
would anybody argue that the titan class
ability isn't by far the worst like
without a doubt the worst one
could anybody make that argument you
know how i know it's the worst one
because there's only one exotic that is
about
the the class ability site and rampart
every other class like half of their
exotics are like oh now your dodge does
this you're well does this it's titan's
it's like two capris capri horn where
you shoot off the firewall
literally i've never used capris
unless it's a nuke in front of that wall
it is not worth it i promise
part of other titan exotics the
intrinsic perk is that this perk doesn't
even make you think about your class
ability that's part of its benefit is
that you don't have to think about how
bad your wall is
uh yeah so i'm just glad that uh i'm
glad that that some of the other classes
are at least getting some hate if our
walls can't get you
i would like to point out that here it
doesn't say it's not getting hit in pve
that was my one that was my one actual
main question it was like i was like i
may not like facing them in pvp but in
pve hunters can be kind of squishy
because that is their kind of defense to
get out of it and i was wondering if you
guys thought
will this make like because i mean they
do their invis dodges stuff like that i
mean that's kind of a whole thing do you
guys think this is going to be
detrimental for pve stuff for hunters i
think it'll make solo gms a lot harder
uh i haven't i haven't done the math on
it but crutching double coyotes with
double dodges is the way to to do that
and uh it'll be really interesting to
see how that works
the other dodge build is top tree arc
strider with a liar's handshake but that
exotic i think gives you your dodge back
immediately on a on a melee kill or that
subclass does one of the two and so i
think that'll circumvent this change
um i yeah i think it'll be very
interesting though yeah man this
there'll be a lot of salty hunties with
this one man like pvp that was the
crutch bro you throw something at them
they do that little roll and they out
and the tracking got broke
yeah i mean there's a little part of me
that empathizes a little bit because of
that's all they think they still have
stompies dude dumb true they got
starving right but there's a part of me
that is always annoyed with a hunter
with that so
look man it's a new meta you're gonna
have to adjust
so
i am i will say i am sorry to the
hunters if this does mess with you guys
in pve
being a titan i am less sad in the pvp
field for the hunters and that is
probably 100 a bias point of view i'll
claim it and that's fine now you're
gonna have to get good hunters i don't
know if you can tell oh it means less
backers as well
and so they can't just like all the way
across everywhere yep yeah huge huge big
change
and that and that that that stasis
freeze dodge that they do oh the
bombardier dodge
oh my god dude that is just toxicity
yeah
top tree arc strider now somebody will
just have to remind me why this is a
thing but i will say the reduction is
hilariously large
this change to the combination below
melee was made possible by our variable
ability cooldown system previously top
tree arcstriders were basically required
to use gambler's dodge with this tree we
hope this change makes this ability more
viable even if you're using marksman's
dodge they reduce the base cooldown of
combination below from 96 seconds
to 15
that is a 600 or more reduction
of that cooldown um somebody remind me
what combination blow like what's the
benefit here what's it doing that's
that's what i was talking about with the
large handshake where you have to you
dodge melee dodge to get your melee back
hit again and the subclass has a is just
pretty much just dodge melee dodge melee
dog that's how people are used to solo
riven
um
and so yeah this is this will
kind of offset that although like i said
if you get a melee kill it automatically
gives you your dodge back which works
perfectly with gambler's dodge already
so i don't think this change is going to
do anything i mean it's awesome but you
know i don't really think it'll make
that big of a difference
and then bottom tree night stalker the
vanish in smoke melee has low damage
output but high utility uh our data
shows that the subclass tree is
struggling in pvp so we decided to
increase how often pathfinder hunters
can go invisible that's never anything i
want to see uh they reduced the base
cooldown from 96 to 75.
so they get more invisibility with that
one so we will just have to see
well we've got a few of these in here
titans
ha
we've got some changes coming as well
and i cannot talk about it i cannot wait
to see how skeptical can possibly be
about any discussion don't worry i got
one for you too it's fine
yeah that's what i'm here for let's just
go i don't think you know dude hold on i
don't think anybody biased and say this
cognito i'd like you to read out the
titan changes because
you can't shut up about it so this is
yours did something happen no
look in our efforts to put the emphasis
back on gun play
we decided to reduce the number of
abilities that can one shot and at full
fix your face e health guardian as such
the titans three show the charges are no
longer one shot abilities in pvp so to
balance it out they made some quicker
charges to activate easy to hit travel
farther they're still powerful pvp and
uh they said which was short-ranged
weapons and used as a movement tool so
they wanted to curb shoulder charge
potency now that they've turned down
shotguns as their current counter so
they're gonna be monitoring so as of now
all shoulder charges no longer one-shot
players sprint activations reduced from
1.5 seconds to 1.25 increased the range
from 5.5 to 6.8 targeting code width
increased by i guess 10
and um increased damage by versus pve
combatants by 25
and then we got seismic strike
specifically the aoe damage is from uh
reduced from 90 to 40. now blinds
enemies in the area on hit interesting
increased base cooldown from 82 seconds
to 90 seconds then shield bash um reduce
the aoe damage from 90 to 40 increase
base cooldown from 82 seconds to 90
seconds hammer strike solar charge will
be um reduced direct impact damage from
170 to 120 and increase base cooldown
from 82 seconds to 90 seconds so either
floor is yours i just want to know how
you felt about all this stuff
i mean i'm not surprised i mean they're
getting towards gun play so i mean the
same thing happens to
shatter dive same thing happened to one
of yours coming up and it is one of
those that i'm not surprised about um my
curiosity is kind of going to be how it
feels in pve
depending on if any of these changes
like when they lower the base damage
like if a shoulder challenge feels like
a tickle to an enemy now that i'm not
going to be a fan of because i should
still be able to do that in pve um said
no longer one shotting the sprint active
cooldown is gonna be a quarter second
faster
doesn't really change a whole lot
basically for me like as a titan
personally
i don't know why i'm gonna use a
shoulder charge in pvp because if i'm
not gonna kill him
i'm gonna have a little wider angle i'm
gonna do more damage to pve enemies but
in pvp i'm gonna get close and i'm gonna
get blasted or i'm gonna get melted the
whole way in still not kill them gonna
have to like readjust and pull out my
weapon i'll be dead by the time i get
there so
basically i'm to me it doesn't seem like
they're going to be very useful in pvp
that just could be me though yeah i
could well i mean if you do like the uh
the stasis melee if you spam your melee
like you'll go you'll like hit him and
then punch him immediately and i'm
wondering if you can do that with this
too maybe it's just it's still i mean
it's an animation there's an animation
that happens after you do the charging
melee
i mean the same thing with the stasis
one though like it doesn't just end like
it zooms back out or whatever or it
zooms out and then zooms back in but you
can still like bam bam i don't it'll be
interesting to see i don't i don't know
um i think i like that they're adding
the movement to it i think yeah that's
huge yeah the bigger range that's good
yep yeah uh yeah honestly i i'm not hurt
at all by this a because i've never used
the shoulder charge in pve like i i
don't even really know what you would
use it for except for the burn effect
that the titans have you know the boss
melting yeah melee but other than that
like why would you ever who would be
worthy of you spending like seven
seconds to get the run-up time to do a
shoulder charge on like you know i'm not
shoulder charging like a fallen vandal
like what would be the point of that you
know yeah unless i'm trying to do the
static electricity thing with the dune
marchers yeah there's not much use on
most because i don't play i typically
hit bottom tree titan so i haven't used
the every soft on you shoulder charge is
like yup that's a cheesy kill totally
get it
but i don't i haven't used it that often
because i've been enjoying enjoying
actually the bottom tree for like the
sun warrior because if i can stand in
one of those places where i get that
little sunwarrior spot my abilities are
just like climbing up
uh and then also just setting stuff on
fire but i was like yeah i enjoy the
occasional time i'll set a dude on fire
watch him walk away and have it trickle
down and be like
those are the fun little moments when
you actually get to watch them in pvp if
you're charging somebody face on with
shoulder charge they're
if they're good at all nine times out of
ten they're gonna shotgun you
in one hit you before you can actually
get a shoulder charge off so that's like
a gambit that's really not good if
you're playing against people that know
what they're doing and so you know it's
it hasn't really been useful to me in
pvp the way it is useful to me is if i
can use it for maneuverability and so
the fact that they're changing it up to
be more about maneuverability
you know when you do hit it it's got
better tracking and that sort of stuff i
think that stuff's more valuable than it
being a one hit and honestly i've
probably gotten killed by people
shoulder charging me
way more than i've ever gotten kills
using it so this is sort of probably
helping me too like i'll get and the
only reason i get killed by is just
because i'm not expecting it like i'm
like oh my god who uses shoulder charge
it's such a rookie move you know like
that's that's the way people get kills
in pvp when they don't know how to shoot
anything
it is dude it just is that's like this
that's the uh the noob starter kit
you showed that shaving that's what
you're doing
just so it's so cheesy man it's so cheap
as new red said i'm sure fallout will
have a before and after
video showing oh yeah all of this fun
stuff oh yeah you already did it
okay this one i do have to say though
this is one of those points where i'm
like this change is pointless
barricade
even with rally barricade changes we
made in season the lost using this
ability during a firefight is still a
risky proposition we've spaced out the
cooldowns of the two barricades to make
the choice slightly more interesting
my hindquarters are what's on the line
there because towering barricade is
three seconds longer duration rally
barricade's five seconds shorter no
one's using rally barricade in pvp
no one i can tell you why do they want
them to like no
what are you doing stop trying to make
fetch happen like this is one of those
moments to where i'm just like no one is
using a half body barricade
it's full body or you're doing something
else like there is no point for rally
bearing
bungee i will use rally barricade and
pvp if you give me 50 silver every time
i deploy
that's my deal
get me to use it bungie has like this uh
fixation on unstoppable sidearms in
making rally barricade work in the pvp
it's like neither are going to happen
cut it out like
it's just like
like i'm not going to use rally
barricade in pve either i don't need
like extra range in there or have my
upper body and my head is exposed that
at least let him shoot my toes or some
crazy like there is zero point for a
rally bear i'm sorry you gotta change it
up or something you have a marksman's
dodge and you have a gambler's dodge
with very different effects
bring it back on a reload
yeah half a wall and a full wall
that ain't it sorry you guys just aren't
playing three-dimensional chess okay you
use a rally barricade to protect your
feet from those telesto orbs all right
there you go the ground hit the rally
barricade
yeah there you go there you go
functional there's the functional
application thank you boys and protect
those thank you
i think you meant 4d chess not 3d chess
[Laughter]
behemoth
again a class i've barely played since i
got the subclass like literally hardly
use it um
we're hoping these changes they make to
diamond lance
um will make it a top-tier pve pick
i think they're reaching still but we
will find out
shiver strike isn't getting a big damage
buff during glacial quake the whisper of
chains fragment buff here is very spicy
and should help behemoth's survivability
in pve uh whisper of changes all
subclasses they're just showing it here
so diamond lance increases the fragment
slots from one to three so you've got
more fragment options
now spawns a diamond lance a pawn
killing a pve combatant with a stasis
weapon
like okay you're gonna see those
apparently for i don't know what the
global cooldown is but if you're just
getting hand cannon kills or a couple
shotguns or reeds regret now there could
be a lot more of those around there
killing three players with stasis
weapons in a single life
killing an enemy with a stasis ability
and shattering an enemy
so all of those will create diamond
lances so in theory they're going to be
everywhere
now
scaro
travis
have you guys done much with the diamond
lances
no but this will slot in perfectly with
an egg receptor built like
yeah that's
titans already have
uh some utility they're probably the
weakest of the three classes with the
with aeger's scepter
definitely definitely but i think this
is like
this will help that out yeah and any
class can pick that lance up right did
they make that change at one point yeah
it's any player can yeah so
um
yeah i think this will be a really good
yeah like you said support thing but i
think for like ad clear in general
age is built it's gonna be sweet yeah
that'll be fun it is nice that that we
do actually have that now because that
makes faces more appealing with the yeah
you guys got the weakest out of the
station
yeah
you got it because it was like
warlocks like now you get negative
movement speed if you're on the stasis
tightness
i feel like you take more damage while
you're inside
yeah i think they took our damage
resistance and they're like all right
you're going to take 10 more damage
amplification here we go
that's not fair shiver strike is going
to do 15 more in pve for
the
i can tell for i don't know if it's just
me and you guys tell me as like again
could be crappy skill how many
uh behemoth just a regular melees have
you guys missed
oh uh just so the truth the trick is
yeah i did i actually did a short on
this when it first launched the trick is
is when you wind up you let go of the
melee like a second early and then it
locks on but if you're holding it it
breaks your tracking
yeah it's
not very intuitive i will say that so
yeah let go earlier
there's no explainer for this in-game uh
and and the super too that's like the
really important thing like
you need to let go of the melee early so
and that's when it'll do like the final
lunch thing yep
they also said whisper of chains
increases pve resistance um
verse combatants by
from 20 up to 40 that's a pretty
substantial damage reduction and his
chains what when you're standing next to
a crystal you get damage reduction is
that right something like that
i don't remember what it does i don't
play i don't play stasis
fragments that are one word different
not a good strat i never know what the
hell any of them are it's a whisper
you know what you know it's crazy if
you're a content creator people on
internet will get mad at you if you
don't know what each of the fragments is
yeah
they're like oh you don't know about the
whisper of malarkey and i'm like dude
i've never heard of that at all i don't
think i'm reading these things
what does it do you gotta give me the
numbers yeah tell me what it does and
i'll i'll be real with you but like what
do you think i don't play the game like
fair enough bottom tree striker this
class is obviously dominating pvp so
we're tuning it down a notch the changes
we made in fists of the havoc and season
lost have helped the tree as intended
but they also turned bottom tree into a
monster so basically they're going to
try and tone down this crazy crazy super
they said knock out the melee lunge
range and melee damage bonus now
deactivate after a melee kill trample
the super energy gain from fist of havoc
now decays to basically caps out at
three and you're gonna get very little
super energy after three pvp kills pve
not affected frontal assault increased
the base goal down from 82 to 106 so
made that one longer and then fist of
havoc heavy slam radius is reduced by
two meters that's actually pretty big
but it is only bottom tree so if you
want the bigger slams of radius you can
still go top tree so they're really
making that bottom tree that can last
longer a bit weaker you have to be a bit
more direct with it for sure
it's pretty dominant yeah yeah for sure
uh [ __ ]
yo warlocks y'all i was like you sure i
got i was like you want this one i gotta
give it to you just grab it give me give
your
this could be fun warlocks have been
losing the slap fights too long scarole
up until now warlocks haven't been able
to
uh melee back to back as quickly as
titans thunders no more
palm slaps y'all so
we're removing the one meter range
extension warlocks received to
compensate we still think the idea of
having class having if each class have a
unique ability qualities to their melee
is interesting but we want to do it in a
way that won't cause one class to
consistently lose slap fights so
uncharged melee reduced melee range from
5.5 meter to 4.5 now matches the hunter
and the titan reduced suppression time
after melees can now melee back to back
at the same speed as hunters
this is a this is a net buff by the way
because yes
uh
pretty much or most warlocks run
affiliations yeah i just want to say
that yep it's like so the range nerf
doesn't even matter right and and now
you can melee faster yes it's on nice
yeah it's all in with ophelia's baby big
nice just put the powder on the hand
that starts
anyway oh yeah so middle tree boy walker
here we go so handheld supernova e's
favorite is getting the shoulder chance
thank god
i knew he was gonna say this i just let
you read this segment you need to read
this because i
no this is all yours i just want to hear
your tears come through the microphone
listen hey hello superzova will no
longer one shot to compensate it down
travels farther and pushes enemies back
we've also increased the damage of
handheld supernova and nova warp versus
champion and boss combatants we
increased the damage the season of the
loss but we felt he could use more juice
so now honestly i will say before you
say all these but like all of what's
going on
it's still going to be very functional
and almost like
potentially more for the amount of
damage it does
plus the like what the range is like
yeah your cleanups are not going to be
that hard with this i think it's still
going to be very good still got the
charge on pvp but i hear what you're
saying for sure reduced damage versus
players now deals 150 damage max
increased damage versus champions and
bosses by 30 that's good increased
projectile range from 12 meters to 14
meters hmm
now pushes targets away from the warlock
or detonation and then we got nova warp
increased damage versus champions and
bosses thank god it's the most useful
useless i still think didn't it just get
a 50 buff too yeah and it still didn't
feel good to me no man that's why
they're doing but that's just like damn
that's how bad it was yeah like 50 and
then 30 more i'll see you in the next
patch when they buff it again yeah bro
it is it is laughable like the bosses
laugh at me stomp and get me out like
why are you even using overwatch
i've tried it since that buff i was like
this is a joke i can't even what about
killing with this
i don't know man i don't know about that
one that's like a pretty uh
a pvp super i think
just the way it's designed i think
you're gonna have a hard time making
that good in pve but they're trying to
keep me hey man
make novel warp great again that's fine
no also with nova 3.0
combined with these buffs nova 3.0 could
be good now this is the big one
shade binder
we feel that shane fighter is in a
pretty good place with a couple of sec
exceptions winter's wrath is still the
best super for shutting down other
supers it's not even close as a general
rule roaming super shouldn't be able to
one shot other supers that penumbral
blast melee is too difficult to land
against pve combatants yes ex travis is
clapping oh i will see you just missed
it oh i missed your clap too we made the
ability harder you should be clapping it
sucks come on you've you've been hit by
this right you've seen another warlock
use the song you've just been like wow
that did not feel good it's a bit
oppressive
i was a bit oppressive a
yeah and then all they have to do is be
on the same half of the map as you do i
remember
i remember when stasis first dropped and
everybody was all mad and i'm like yo
warlock is lit like i was loving warlock
stasis yeah but now i haven't i just got
screwed the entire time so hopefully you
enjoyed your year so they talk about the
pve negative effect and then they've
increased their proximity detonation
radiance against pve combatants to make
it easy to land now all three stasis
grenades now have different cool down
times all right this one's big we made a
change to bleak watcher to avoid a
situation in which it is always the best
you to use the grenade with the shortest
cooldown time the resulting overall
cooldown increase for bleak watcher
which fits its incredibly high power
output that's a big deal that is my
high-end build from so for people who
don't play warlocks for example yeah
tell us what bleak water is doing for
you what is that turret yeah you charge
up that grenade you throw that turret
down you can control space you can
stasis things it's really oppressive it
has some good functionality in pvp would
you agree scarole or are you a bleak
watcher oh no that turrets uh i'm not
i'm not a huge uh weak watcher guy okay
uh it's i mean it's it's annoying in pvp
and pve i don't really play okay like i
said if i'm playing pve on warlock i'm
like top tree dawn
skating like as fast as i can i got it
so this is for me it is for me yeah yeah
this is my end game one of my end game
builds and i can really control
nightfall but anyway winter's wrath so
again reduce the shatter pulse damage
versus enemy supers must now generally
freeze and shatter all supers twice
to eliminate that's a big deal plum bass
um increased proximity detonation radius
versus pve combatants by 100 and
bleakwatcher while equipped all stasis
grenades charge at glacier grenade rate
that's it
well travis i don't know if that's
enough but we'll see
i don't know if i don't know if two full
breaks really
changes anything if the tracking is
still ridiculous and you can still get
blown up from across the map yeah like
if you can give me one up and then
freeze me a second right usage is high
it uses a lot of super energy to do that
okay
you know what else uses a lot of super
energy any of the titan supers that are
just one shot and not roaming at all
like you know what i mean like um
and then blast and then freeze me again
how much of an opportunity am i going to
have a chance to still fight you
that's my question
honestly the super is probably done at
that point because it might be but you
just saved yourself a super kill like
that's if you can survive a super and
still shut one down
yeah yeah if you can still shut down a
super
and live like completely unscathed not
like right almost a trade that's still
pretty potent that's all i'm saying no
it's not potent there's still pawn i'll
give you that
uh you're melee getting a buff though
that's big because i know that thing
sucks for a little while so that's
terrible terrible
but yeah that was that the last of them
which i think the last word
end it cut it cut the recording it's
done
you said that earlier
[Laughter]
yeah this is the part i want to talk
about destiny 2 leaving xbox game pass
because it's major and the way its
handle goes into a deeper discussion
we've been having for weeks now
on december 8th destiny 2 and its
expansions forsaken shadow keep and
beyond light
will leave xbox game pass on cloud and
console now one caveat there forsaken
campaign as we discussed is going free
on december 8th
but apparently not some other things
destiny 2 and current expansions will
remain on xbox game pass for pc because
i think they just
they just got there pretty recently
right they just played just put it out
yeah so once destiny 2 leaves xbox game
pass for consoles and cloud apparently
uh players who don't own any of the
expansions on xbox platform will lose
access to
campaign missions expansion-specific
activities raids dungeons hunts exo
challenges nightfall strikes access to
trials of osiris which is actually a
thing for three months
um the stasis subclass which is beyond
light specific the middle tree supers
which i did not see
and the ten percent off perk for silver
purchases and other game add-ons
okay i'm gonna go last anybody else
gonna go first
oh move it off guys
wait
there you
go we do we think it'll come back next
year
i feel like it must yeah yeah my guess
is yes but i think the reason they
haven't announced it yet is probably
because they're hoping to get that first
lump of sales and pre-orders and then
once the game is actually out like three
weeks in they'll be like all right cool
now that we've sold 10 million copies of
the witch queen it's gonna be free for
anybody who didn't buy it and then
they'll
drop it right before you know shadow
keep leaves yeah and just keep it going
yeah right before a
light fall
i i get it from a business perspective i
don't like it but also xbox getting
stuff for free and not like playstation
or like
you know me yeah that's not for me
how much how much does xbox game pass
it's like 50 bucks a month 15 15. 15. oh
i was like what the [ __ ] all right
15. okay that's about what we end up
paying anyway nevermind whatever screw
these guys buy the game
[Music]
[Laughter]
it is weird to give it to him and then
take him take it away probably only to
give it to them again
yeah it's interesting i was surprised by
this one travis i'm sorry you was about
to continue talking about about that you
go oh you go
there yeah no it's just interesting i
was like okay
and then the other thing i was thinking
about it was the the the role of the dcv
in this
because it's currently so annoying it's
unclear
like when you buy when it's gonna go
when's it gonna come back like okay
shadow keep guaranteed to go next year
but they introduced a new destination is
that gonna go do we know for sure is
dreaming city gonna stay
none of this has like an expiration date
that's very public until they decide to
tell you in a post here but we still you
can still literally go on steam probably
right now if i pull up steam which i
don't want to pull it up right this
second would you still probably go on
steam right now buy forsaken
right now
and we've already talked about that
anyway continue what you were going to
say no that's pretty much it it is
surprising but at the same time i i
think i'm with tribe i think this is one
of those plays
bungie and xbox whatever the
relationship is
you know it it served its purpose
destiny is still one on xbox one of the
in the top 10 games as of like two days
ago i was checking which is surprising
because it's one of the most deadest
seasons right now right considering for
the hardcore community and to see it
have that much engagement i'm like wow
so to me it's like okay they probably
put things in destiny content vault
rearrange the structure get the well the
bungee 30th anniversary money get the
witch queen pre-orders and then as it
gets closer to february oh maybe by the
way
you know we throw in witch queen that
expansion in um in game pass for console
users because it doesn't make sense also
that it also remains on pc that to me is
also weird like if it's going to be
removed remove it completely and it to
me it was weird that xbox game pass or
destiny on pc came so late so to me
that's it it gives me the impression
they still have more things they want to
do with bungie and game pass so that's
just my guess i could be wrong but uh i
think i wouldn't be surprised if witch
queen at some point whether it be at
launch
or at some point is going to come back
in into game pass that's my theory
that's what i'm running with yeah
yeah so i i as i said i think that makes
sense i don't i don't think it makes a
ton of sense to
have stuff like stadia where people can
just play it uh on demand and not have
it on xbox which is a much larger
platform the difference is that on
stadia you also have to buy the game
right so
i mean they gave away the destiny 2 uh i
think it was beyond light or shadow keep
i think it was shadow keep that year
when it came out
um but yeah you still have to pay for
the expansion so that's the difference
but
um
the way they're doing it is terrible
yeah
and i think we've talked about this now
like seven or eight weeks in a row about
how destiny's model doesn't make any
sense yep right like
uh
you
the fact that we're paying for
microtransactions and season passes and
the main expansions and you know just
across the board like
their model keeps developing and turning
into this thing that is a game as a
service but their pain their paying
model their financial model is just
stuck in in you know
2014 like they haven't changed at all
and uh i i think uh
that needs to change like soon or it's
just gonna
it's just gonna drive people away and i
i i thought when they went on game pass
it was there kind of like hinting at
like hey we're going full free to play
eventually right maybe there will be
some way that they make you
pay like via game pass because that way
they're getting money for sure or if it
goes on playstation now or what have you
but that's essentially the same thing
right it's like a premium free to play
game where you have to you have to have
some sort of like subscription to
something that gives you access to it
but then everything in it all the
content is free and you just have to pay
for micro transactions and season passes
and i think that model would probably
work for them i don't understand why
they also need to
create all these gates because
there's this uh
really interesting conversation
happening in the gaming industry right
now where people are finding out that
the more barriers you add you actually
make less money and so if you say nobody
can play my game unless they pay 60
then that means that
you just lost a whole group of people
that aren't willing to pay 60 and then
the next year when you do it again you
add another barrier it's like adding
hurdles to a track for people that are
running track right like you're going to
lose people with every track
unless they're professionals and can can
run so
metaphor
but uh but but but
if you if you break down those barriers
and say okay anybody can keep playing
along but we're just going to sell you
stuff as you go we're going to sell you
guys water bottles that we're going to
hand to you as you're making the run
right if you do that then because the
barrier is so low there's just a huge
pool of people that are playing imagine
how many fewer players would be playing
apex right now if you had to pay for
that game yeah like because that barrier
is gone completely people just play apex
like mad and all absolutely all their
support down the road is free and they
just sell people microtransactions so i
think one way or another bungie's going
to learn that
you can't you can't keep adding barriers
of entry and expect people to continue
to play your your game at least at the
levels that they
have have enjoyed in the past and i
think bungie only gets away with this
because they're the special kid on the
block they're the exception to the rule
because they sort of created this genre
and they have this cult following of
people like our guest today that
literally can't bring himself to not do
everything in destiny every season
i'm afraid my wife will leave me if i'm
not a max time score game yeah so i got
to keep it up you know
she she will for sure she messages me
about it so
ridiculous you know uh wow
wow
wow
[Laughter]
yeah uh but but you know i just think uh
they this is something they're gonna
have to address sooner or later they're
not gonna be special forever
and uh they they gotta they gotta show
up they got they gotta they have to
change their model and i think that i
think they will have to do that
eventually yeah it's just too too many
models and too many forms of
monetization but to i want to shout out
a wd prescott he actually had a good
point to bring it to you guys he said
what do you guys think that it is uh
contractual issues that the end date was
supposed to be when which i think that
makes
initially right because technically
which queen was going to be around this
time so it was just going to roll over
but with the delay he said do you think
it messed it all up and i think there's
some truth to that i mean i think the
delay for this weird because now you get
people who
jumped into game jumped in destiny with
game pass they have beyond light they've
been able to play trials up until now
then you're gonna have this weird two
and a half month window where they can't
play trials
right even though they were able to up
until now yet the next expansion's not
out so why would you put buy beyond
light at the end of this thing that
you've already played the most out of
at that point you'll just wait for which
queen and then you're just going to fall
off the game for a little while so
so that's the thing
even even if they waited and bought
witch queen today let's say that it left
game pass as planned and which queen
came out today and they bought it
if they did that they would still lose
their stasis subclass oh i know i mean
that's still a thing because they would
buy it beyond light right so it wouldn't
fix the problem it still would have been
weird oh no
this is so so messy because yeah you've
got a subclass that you spent
nine months with or ten months or
however long we're at now and then all
of a sudden it's like unlocked all of
the
artists and fragments i'm like is it
just gonna be unlocked
well it's like i would imagine it's just
like grayed out and you have to go like
please buy
but it's like and they state that you
know there's gonna be discounts on
expansion soon but
it's i mean you're getting to the point
where why the hell are you charging for
shadow keep
for one also game pass players if you
listen to this thing
forsaken you're gonna have a little time
to work on it there's gonna be a pack
shadow keep if you have game pass right
now do that stuff right now go get your
death breaker go get your xenophage do
anything related to shadow keep now
because forsaken's gonna be a little
different and you'll be able to buy that
stuff but i was like shadow keep
especially that's the stuff that one's
so weird because like the moon shadow
keep was it's old forsaken's insanely
old why they're still charging for that
one i don't know like shadow keeping for
a second should be free
yeah beyond light goes for a year
they're gonna make all their money for
like a hundred dollars for the 30th
anniversary in which which queen when
which queen launches beyond light should
be free because as you guys said you're
putting up a wall
then you don't own this one here's
another wall and then another wall and
that stuff's like three years old
nobody's gonna play it anyway but if you
want to jump in
i mean there's a reason final fantasy is
so successful right now and they've got
to look at that because final fantasy 14
my brother told me he's like dude
there's like 300 hours of stuff for free
like there's so much for free is it the
current story no but there's so much
that he can go in
explore and the destiny content vault
makes this worse by the way which is a
whole different problem
i was like and that's the problem is now
you like oh the campaign's gonna go well
how do i know what the hell happened go
watch some youtube videos you're telling
me i can't play the the red war 16 story
campaign i can't see
who the
barons are gone every one of the baron
fights that was like a unique boss that
you'd go through
all of those are going to be gone so
you're losing content and you're still
charging them for this like half piece
of things it's like and bungie it's like
we love you but this has got to get
simplified because you're just making it
harder for any person to say hey should
you play i'm like
i don't even know what you get anymore
you're gonna buy witch queen and say
okay well if you buy witch queen now
what if i pre-order witch queen does
that help me out no which queen will
only get you into trials in february but
if you buy witch queen white and they're
right they don't they don't even do that
you can't even like pre-order which
queen now to be like all right if i
don't want to buy beyond light but i
pre-order witch queen will that let me
play trials for the next couple months
no seriously no like
that's not even one like a concession
that they're making stasis the middle
tree supers is insane though that i
never even thought that i don't feel
good that'll you log in the next day
your joint is gone now my question is
the middle tree supers are those even
going to be available in which queen are
those going to be free with witch queen
when forsaking is completely like kind
of gone or is that going to be just like
you have to buy the forsaken pack to get
the middle tree supers because those are
big you got chaos reach you've got
sentinel shields there's so many like uh
blade barrage there's some big supers
that people use for very specific
circumstances
like if you have to buy a forsaken pack
to buy those they're getting so yeah i'm
sorry but they're getting ready the
forsaken pack doesn't leave with witch
queen though right well that's last wish
swish is still here the dungeon's still
here
so
they wouldn't make any product if they
planned on making that all free later
yes yeah yeah i think it's here it's
here to here to pay
no i mean that's and that's the problem
here to say come on that was good thank
you whatever
it's exacerbated by the fact that it's
like oh are you buying witch queen or
the deluxe edition or the collector's
edition or the deluxe plus the 30th
anniversary plus four seasons you know
it's like yeah
what the and then it's like oh yeah you
have to buy witch queen deluxe and 30th
anniversary but hey also if you really
want to do the good stuff get last wish
or get your forsaken pack get shadow
keep if you want to run like that right
those supers have been in the game for
three years by the time this comes out
you should not be charging for those i'm
sorry like yeah
that's ridiculous like beyond light
after a year especially like if you had
game pass for a year
like you know say somebody's got a cert
like have you played for like five
minutes maybe not but if you played for
like hundreds of hours in your game and
you didn't have beyond light like you
should get like some pass or something
like check a box in the system that you
can keep beyond light because like you
buy it right now before witch queen just
because it goes at a game pass for this
two this two and a half month limbo
which i know is caused by the delay i'm
sure because prescott's probably dead on
accurate of that but that limbo makes it
so much worse feeling right now i think
to me yeah i don't feel good
anytime you log in and something's
grayed out
yeah that don't feel like that's just
unless it's telesco unless it's lost
yes yes i think that one's just going to
be a black box and it's just deleted
week at bungie we've sunset telesto
that would be hilarious we brought back
sunset
for one thing and that's the only thing
that that's the only way
there's no way it's that easy otherwise
they would have tried it already i'm
guessing if they tried to sunset to
lester celeste would be like i'm the
captain now
i can't do it like no i'm not going
oh man
good old celeste no but yeah this is my
here's my proposal for for this what'd
you get fine if you want to take away my
super sub classes
because i didn't buy your your your
expansions fine but i demand you create
in in-game story content that gives me a
reason why i'm losing my powers
i'm talking i want gal to come back and
like set my power again i want you know
i want to kick you he kicked you in the
middle nut of all your subclasses yeah i
to pop out and see me using the darkness
and be like you can't use that guardian
take it away
and that way i can't use my my shadow
dive that that's that would be okay as
long as there's a story reason for it
then
oh my god yeah
bungee sometimes man
it's only the business side yeah of
bungie like i did i don't i feel like
there's like a separate group of people
there but someone that some of the
things they do is just like
bro
it's literally the business side versus
the dev side and i've learned to
separate it because it's just like i
don't want to get mad at this this
studio that makes this these great
things that we love but it's just like
business side just be they've been so
egregious dude it's every it's like and
it's like every egg season and expansion
yeah transmog stuff oh god
yeah you know you had like the people
then like the vault of glass cosmetics
it's like every season there's something
else it's like i get it to some extent
but like did you guys see outriders just
absolutely just spank them on transmog
yeah no micro transactions no like
totally shopping across all classes like
they do subliminally
here you go late yeah that's the one
thing i really like about uh outriders
marketing is like they have taken a shot
every time they can yeah they're like
like call people out directly yes every
time it's like we need someone like that
to like
to get people a little bit nervous you
know
and i'm kind of glad that this this new
expansion for them is seems to be their
their play time is up or their hours
their way up on steam i think that's the
worst possible thing i know all the time
like i got a chance to know that that
was coming and i was like oh
yeah i was like
i almost wanted to be like you guys
oughta you guys ought to move this
because it's going to get lost it's it
is
a world slayer is going to come out week
of uh witch queenie
oh yeah oh yeah
no world slayer is going to drop the
same day as uh
what i'm trying to think of breath of
the wild too
yeah they came out i think what it is is
they probably thought they were safe in
november and they didn't anticipate the
the stealth multiple players remember
november was like the one
right
yeah that was dumb that was stupid they
should not have launched it
i mean it's cool i'm glad they did and
and that and i'm glad there's so many
apparently it's on sale right now on
steam for like 66 like if it's 20
dollars go play outriders it is 100
percent worse the campaign the campaign
alone was fantastic i think i never
finished it yeah i gotta finish it too
yo
because i gotta finish yeah you guys
cause honestly the things that we took
up with you [ __ ] hey baby
say that for the after dog
shout out to rgh and their after
discussions
we've got a whole different podcast
going now guys as as a consolation
player as gay gay pass holders you can
now you've lost you know destiny you
could go to our writers
we've purchased one copy of anthem for
everyone losing your forsaken sub yo
go enjoy this five five mission campaign
and nothing to do that was the thing
you're still on game pass
yeah i was still rocking and rolling
noise yeah still rocking it right there
were people saying there were like
rumors that it was only there for a
month and they were like oh it's
basically free trial but i guess yeah
it's sticking around yeah we're still
doing it oh yeah outraiders are one of
those like everybody asked me is like is
the game good i'm like dude i played
that thing i played like 60 hours that
first week because i got a little early
access i got to be in the insider
program and i played like hard the day
early or something like that and then i
played like i played through campaign my
buddy and i were grinding the end game
he had his inventory wiped cog couldn't
log in for a month so i'm like there
were technical issues that were awful
it's like and i completely get that but
i'm like
the things it did with like the ability
combinations and like you could put one
mod and all of a sudden your ability
completely changes you can put like
three mods and you're like i have got to
your ability like the way they manage
the
their sandbox of fun that you could use
for i'm really only focused on one class
and there's four of them like the way
they managed to make so many of the
abilities in that game fun the weapons
unique like
and as you said the story i never
expected for one to be that long
and two actually did not be terrible for
like a shooter story it was like there
were like a couple of twists and i was
like whoa
this is i never saw that coming i think
anthem suffered from end game problems
and inaccessibilities with different
characters because you had to run past
that 50-hour campaign again every time
you saw the character yeah and it was
and obviously like the the inventory
wipes and all that yeah that actually
happened to me too i was in the beta i
was trying to get i'd like spent like 50
hours farming that stood that one
captain that's coming
yeah because i wanted every every exotic
yeah legendary yeah because i was going
to do like a rank one of my ranking
videos and then i get i'm literally one
off log in all of them gone and i was
just like oh
never doing that again yeah you're like
i'm done yeah yeah it's like it's a
testament to how much i love that game
because i couldn't access it for a while
but i was still so feed to play yeah and
i was just like every time i log in i'm
in my underwear again i'm like not ready
to play yeah it's it's i mean yeah they
did a great job i hope they keep with it
because there's something special there
but i agree oh yeah the fact that
they're doing an expansion i will
totally play that like world slavery
when that thing comes back i'm like i'm
there like i will totally jump back in
for that one
like and that's one of those things
where it's like
they took and i watched division do the
same thing we've talked about this like
they tried to do the live service like
balance and tuning to make sure things
weren't too powerful i'm like
stop that
yep
let people have fun in your pve game
because it ain't gonna break anything
and it doesn't matter
but like so many things about that game
the inventory quality of life crap that
they had in that game i was like dude
everybody look at what out writers this
random shooter is doing blues all at
once wow i was like
i could have thought if we can't like
not pick up blues and witch queen i'm
afraid it's never going to happen
yeah it's so crazy because it was it
existed it was in destiny 1. this was a
feature this isn't something we've been
asking for something we had and they
took away like it's like
like if you get to farming anything
you're like for the love of god blues go
like everything right
for how many prisms and shards i've lost
it's it's like gotta be in the thousands
for prisms like easily okay i did it's
crazy and it's i know that's also like
oh you shouldn't keep things in your
postmaster it's like you shouldn't cap
materials yeah i shouldn't be capturing
50 in like 10 shots
you can have
99999 weapon parts but you have 999
cores but you can have 10 of this and 50
of this because we have this arbitrary
limitation because if you play our game
too much
right
you can't have can't have too much like
god forbid we stockpile it's like you
make a new currency for every you know
weapon crafting we've talked about this
weapon crafting because i can use my 18
000 weapon parts it's going to use
weapon fragments or some [ __ ] like
yeah there's my curse for the night
sorry within frames
yeah exactly they did that with the
armory dlc they they they usually
yeah it's gonna be weapons
i'm sitting on 18 000 weapon parts and
you're telling me not one of these is a
frame
there's gonna be a couple pieces in here
that make up part of a weapon come on
i've got a lot of them i got a lot to
pick from we definitely got to give our
riders their their roses on that and
they definitely challenged them in ui
management builds and things you could
like switch out the mods and level like
oh i want to level up my weapon click
yeah it's just once you get enough
currency you can do that to anything you
want to like and you can put two two
legendary perks on one gun oh one gun
awesome
i love that aspect of it okay
now y'all gonna make me play dude
it's excellent like don't do it it's
just 100 worth it and now the
expeditions are untimed like that [ __ ]
like they they lowered the timers
four new expeditions four four new
experts four new expeditions and then
the final expedition you have three
legendaries that you'll be able to like
pick from so if you farm that one you'll
actually be able like i want this one of
the three now it's not easy trust me
that
what is it challenge to your 15
expedition is it's a bit of a beating
but the fact that you can choose one of
three and then the legendary vendor guy
he used to just have like eight static
things just forever same ones ever if
you didn't needed them or not that's all
you got now you can re-roll them
so as you farm that in-game resource you
can re-roll him to go after other stuff
as well you can just buy a random
legendary
and i'm just right no i'm a yeah they
definitely need a right they need a true
end game thing i'm a tech no i'm
assuming technique is okay the
devastators get buffed remember
devastating
they've done this there's a lot of
things that i don't know with regards to
like balance patches because they've
done
quite a few balance patches
like since it came out whenever it was
like march or something whenever it
dropped like between now they've been
doing a lot of that type of stuff for
all the subclasses so i know a lot of
them have been touched they buffed quite
a few in this one
um that one overall so i'll check it out
well as we wrap this thing up gonna let
our guests get a little bit i did want
to ask our final question uh for scaro
with regards to which queen
as it is the big hype coming and if you
got anything for the 30th you can say it
too but which queen's the biggest one
what are like two or three
wants for witch queen i know we talked
blues already so you can't use that one
but i mean what are your like
which queen wants whether it's big
little system wide tiny what do you what
do you want to see surprised or
otherwise in which queen
so
please
please punchy please uh so uh i'm gonna
give you two okay uh one and i think
this has to happen it makes so much
sense like i think there has to be some
sort of community puzzle or
or like a live event leading into which
queen like that for on a marketing
standpoint alone they have to do it have
you already seen like the tweets with
the little like store like the murder
board videos that they're doing and
stuff like that those are really well
done too i like those i hope something
those something happens i hope um
i uh okay i'm actually gonna give you a
third one i hope before forsaking this
uh dreaming city's gone whenever that is
we better get a wish
15. there has to be a payoff for them
maybe make the community puzzle to find
wish 15 or something i don't care uh but
my big thing my like true one is is for
the raid of witch queen i you know
sabbath news all about trickery and
stuff i just want it to be the most mind
me like messy crazy rig like you never
know what you're shooting at i want the
mechanics to be crazy
i think back to um i was talking about
this on stream one day i was thinking of
wind waker zelda wind waker the final
boss gannon has like four stages where
he turns into like different stuff like
i want savithoon to do that like yeah
if if she's the
whoever the boss is i just like i oh
well there we go i just wanted to be
like uh
and just endlessly changing just
trickery
i'm with you bro i am so with you i'm
sorry i think if if any concept is going
to top top excuse me uh last wish it's
going to be this one so that's what i
want it's just a fantastic raid no
vaulted glasses no garden of salvations
i want
good
re-runnable crazy raid also i want wrath
of the machine back not king's fall oh
spicy boom by the way let's see right
really fit with the theme but i'm down i
know but i just hate the original that's
what i love
like has to hit
and i want them to really lean into
deception trickery you know like that
would be so cool as a raid boss it would
be different levels or it's not going to
be the raid though the raid's inside the
pyramid right right yeah yeah we're
ready to the pyramid i just want to know
what they do it there's a lot of
pressure on that raid but with kings
yeah there's a lot of pressure on this
raid to really excavate i mean it's
spongy i give them the credit but i want
sabbath dune to hit right i went
thematically to hit right so i always
wanted the raid to be called the queen's
rise the opposite of king's fall
i don't if she was in it that would make
a lot of sense being as like she's
theoretically not in the pyramid or
whatever then maybe but that actually i
really like the title actually i don't
think she's in it but yeah that would be
good we gotta see if she could stick
around we don't know
i wouldn't
fall
yeah i hope we don't just have this like
we said
queen's ball
[Laughter]
those
those are good guys like there's
i think for all of us like the witch
queen will be a more of a flash in the
pan kind of thing i think we're going to
be grinding out some armor we're going
to get some ornaments we're going to get
the exotic and the dungeon will be cool
and it's like you'll be grinding out
some of that stuff but it's like there's
we've talked about this with a lot of
guests and i think there's a lot the
weight on which queen is more than some
people want to give credit to because as
you said it's like we want the ultimate
mechanic raid because it's sabathun in
the world of trickery and we're going to
her throne world and there's you know
we're not getting the subclass but we're
getting void 3.0 and we're getting
weapon crafting we're getting a brand
new weapon type with the glaive which
who knows how that one's going to work
like there's a lot coming with this one
and i think just the weight of which
queen is
there's a lot on it so again
i'm i'm hoping it delivers i'm saying
with you it's like i want that raid to
just blow my socks off to between uh
like the we're in space from t-rex
moment where he's like i'm in space
to the like then you get the
spacewalk and like you have both of
those in a raid and then now they gotta
follow that with this one
yeah i'm really curious because those
two both like atmosphere alone like
those two are like awesome
just don't give me another um skull loss
fight or whatever that way
yeah we fight tedx twice
that's the only thing i took away from
it i never asked scarole how you felt
because we haven't talked in a while how
you felt about deep stone [ __ ] real
quick oh i love it it's fantastic yeah
yeah does it rain higher than vault of
glass
oh eat like
[Laughter]
yeah
yeah
i love uh yeah i love the the
complexity i mean no raid's like really
that complex
but i the how
intricate a lot of the things are and
two-man deep stone crypt is like
probably my favorite raid experience of
all time like wow
a tracks is like an amazing encounter
the only bad thing about a tracks is
like there's like a wall if you kill
everything really quickly there's like a
30-second wall yeah kind of kills it but
if you're two-man in it not even there
you don't even know this it's like two
or three men in the entire thing i did
um last season me and my friend atp we
two-man flawless the entire raid and it
was like
two man tannics is is probably like
my favorite encounter of all time if
it's like what riven legit's like up
there but two main tannics the just
everything that goes into it
it's just so good it's there's not like
any bugs or anything like you're doing
it all legit um
super good i i yeah i have a lot of
respect for deep stone it's not like the
most replayable raid in the world but i
think what it does it does perfectly so
crypt um i'd say it's like top five for
me maybe top seven i don't know it's
hard to say there's too many raids isn't
that like all the raids yeah there's
like 15 raids i think right yeah yeah i
think there's i forget oh you're talking
about the mini raids oh yeah the
apartment
layers uh
leviathan raids hey i love you so much
raiders
they're very different okay i love me
some spire i love me some argos
so uh
salute you would despise brother you
think you you and all five of you
what's your favorite raid lair mine's
crota's wrath
wow
i mean it's better than what's your
least favorite strike vault of glass
until you came in here with the
blasphemy
yeah you're right you stand you stand
still too much involve the glass for it
to be a strike it's a
public event
[Laughter]
thank you guys for joining us this is
the last time you'll be seeing scarole
on the show
hey i've done my time involved the glass
i it took me two i solo to ethiopia
what's your favorite again you were a
king's fall guy right what are you doing
no last wish i i think keemstar is
incredible
that's right yeah yeah i think the orcs
encounter is like one of the worst uh
encounters of all time it's it's like
the it's a perfect encounter to do once
but if you ever do it like more than
once it's just 10 minutes of the same
thing and if you fail you just have to
do it over and over again any encounter
that you can't speed up with a more
skilled team trash encounter i don't
care garbage boycott spicy tanks yeah
it's like gauntlet trash
or it's trash first encounter of crown
trash i don't even care wow i think the
one exception is like siege engine but
that's it's because it's not like
cyclical it's like one very linear
encounter which i like like shiro chi is
the same way yeah i like those
encounters where you're doing the same
thing and you have to do them three or
four times you're like
you're probably one yeah
i think it's easily the weak point of of
uh last week so
look you can lease you consistent i'll
give you that you're consistent
well
but you can to be fair you can speed up
vault if you use uh tractor cannon you
boop out the cap yeah
that's cheating though
[Laughter]
[Music]
that's why you said you didn't like
vaulted glass because there's a lot of
standing on plates waiting oh but that's
like four encounters in a row of
standing verses
so it was a different time and destiny
my friend we were playing on all
xbox 360. have you seen this that's
where i started what they were working
with that's where i started yes i have
i was a 360 gamer and then i was a one
guy
and now i'm a pc master race gamer
he loves that made a huge mistake
that's the way to go that's the way you
do it right there dude
yeah if you want to cheat yeah
we get messy
[Laughter]
is this guy battle eye did someone is he
a plant
i'm a [ __ ] i am battle eye i wonder
that was funny
anyway
all right well as we wrap this thing up
we always like to give our guests a
little bit of time but yeah we got off a
little fun there but actually not the
longest podcast we've ever had with as
much as we had to cover we always do
this no like that's the hilarious thing
i'll say it up front we were like we
were good at like almost two hours
probably could have like wrapped up the
show tight two hours on like one of the
longest swabs ever because like all
right cool bullet point go go go go
there could be like
four bullet points into twab and
three-hour show because we fall off like
a deep end somewhere so
somehow yeah this one turned into be a
reasonable time um but scarole the floor
is yours what you got working on if you
got a time where people can give you a
big shout out for your doctorate when we
can
hopefully we get you on before since you
said a year and a half we got to have
you back before so i can still call you
scaro9 one more time so i don't have to
call you doctor scaro9 because if i want
to tell you that if i have to call you
that then i don't know if we can invite
you back but at least for now
so
i guess just to to do that my i defend
my dissertation may of 2023 if
everything goes well so like 18 17
months um but in terms of like personal
stuff i don't what am i i don't know am
i working on anything i'm on a podcast
tonight there's that screen it's a load
that's right
no i have uh
some stuff happening
yeah i don't know i'm gonna be streaming
that's for sure find this man on the
scaro9 youtube channel he is an
excellent streamer fun dude best hair he
might rock out for you or just scream so
loud when he beats an encounter that he
breaks his own window but both of them
yes that was painful
did you actually hurt your throat when
you did that like a little bit it was it
was bad technique i know a couple
vocalists that would have been like that
was you're screwing up your voice bro
but it was worth it though i mean
absolutely yeah you killed me yeah that
was many many many hours later but shout
out to uh too many now also the uh the
happy couple want to congrats on the uh
marriage by the way since you now have a
no longer girlfriend but a wife my that
dude that was like three years ago i've
been on something oh really yeah yeah
you said that before so you don't dm her
jeez yeah bro come on
come on bro yo
talking to her about the triumph score
come on
uh
20
yeah may 2018. yeah nice so
yeah there we go yes i think oh my god
do i not i was like you might want to
make sure you know when your anniversary
is that's the only thing i'll say i'm
telling you man grad school is crazy
it's like time it's the longest days
shortest years of my life like time does
not exist it's crazy it probably makes
it worse that your grad school is during
a pandemic like that's like compounded
it's so bad i'm sure it is it is worse
in terms of that and like mentality and
like trying to like stay grounded but in
terms of like
why so hiring like
boom tanks deering covet and so like if
i am
it's great because when i'm scheduled to
get out kovid will probably be like on
the rise and there will be a lot of job
positions opening from like you know
people who retired or something and uh
so
it's a it's better for me that it
happened now than in you know two years
but um
uh
yes it has definitely made everything
and my life is like
destiny work destiny work and it's like
that's it just constantly so
now halo
man by the way
nice thank you man
but yeah in terms of like big projects
i'm not i don't know i did fun stuff
with guitar i got a new guitar coming so
i'll probably do a couple a couple of
videos so i can be like tax right off
and uh
uh favorite advanced gg flavor
oh easy strawberry lemonade ah good
choice
i really i really want to scare sweet
tea eventually so yeah we got a yeah you
yeah you need to arrow sweet tea yeah i
like that i live in the south so it's
like thematic even though i like regular
tea better they're like on sweet tea but
i'll play into it whatever
i'll do like uh the one that launches
tomorrow i'm actually excited about yeah
it is have they announced the flavor can
i say it uh
you could probably say it here because
by the time this will be public yeah
it's fine oh cool it's a bomb pop
flavored i don't know
oh
rocket pop so it's that like red white
blue popsicle
i've got mine coming on the way so i can
do like i always do live taste what are
these insane 90s flavors
where they were just having fun and then
i can't wait for uh next week's flavor
the retro cup flavor where it's just it
just tastes like the the white the cup
with the blue and pink stripes on it oh
the uh dixie cup
um
yeah but in terms of like actual stuff
i'm working on i'm just taking it a day
at a time i just finished uh
up to this point i haven't been working
on much because i i had my second of
three defenses was like two weeks ago
hardest defense in grad school typically
at night i passed it so i have nothing
i'm just kind of like surviving right
now i'll get to planning stuff in the
future now like soon but i'm just kind
of just kind of vibing so not a lot of
self-promo there that's all right
let's go watch this man in the streams
hang out always good vibes in there hey
thank you no doubt travis any exciting
things on your do you get to keep
playing halo or
i do get to keep playing halo a little
bit i'm working on the wiki so i'll
probably be posting new articles on the
halo wiki on ign.com every single day
tonight i have to finish all the
vehicles guides for all of them and also
create a guide on how to destroy
vehicles so i've been destroying
vehicles all day i need that i need that
different with different stuff so if you
if you need uh some help on that i'll be
able to help you when that's dropped i
need it okay cool oh yeah dude it's
super easy to destroy vehicles
what is that wasp and i can't just
use any of the shock weapons a two tap
disables it okay okay okay the disrupter
pistol or the shock rifle if you shoot
the pistol
yep the pistol wow or the grenades if
you throw the grenades and it gets it
like flies by it it'll shock everything
near it it'll disable vehicles nice
didn't know that yeah it only disables
it for a few seconds but it's enough
time for you to just like hop in the
cockpit yeah jackie knock the guy out or
something kind of little baby emp effect
to it
just disables it for a couple seconds so
um yeah i'm gonna do that and then uh
you can follow me on twitter at ty guy
travis uh next week i will be posting my
review of uh the nerf video game so i'm
gonna have to take a break from playing
halo to play a nerf gun game then i'm
sure it's gonna be great we'll see wait
is the nerf gal horn in it i'm done yeah
of course yeah nice i have no i have no
idea i have not played it yet so it
comes out tomorrow and for for whatever
reason they've decided to give the
review copies out on the same day the
game comes out oh dude that you know
what that usually means
let's just say i will be playing a game
that is not halo uh
by coercion
who owns nerf is that hasbro
um i i don't know actually it's a great
question um i'm just wondering who
bankrolled this
game oh why really dude i have so many
questions i'm going to dive in tomorrow
and figure out what the who's who's the
developer what else have they made like
yeah if this is their debut game that is
hasbro
yeah this is that's so makes sense i
haven't seen any i have not seen any
advertisements for this game well
let me tell you let me tell you
there's games every day that you don't
know came out
i know this because they make me review
those ones that's mostly what i review
is the games that no one has heard of
hey it's going to be on steam though
look at that yeah maybe i'll pick it up
we can 1v1
absolutely i'm going to shoot you with
the video
it doesn't even you're not even shooting
nerf guns
it's just regular you're just shooting
regular guns this is just fortnite
it is
it looks like a fortnight clone
basically yeah what is going on okay
well yeah so anyway i'm gonna be playing
that nerf the game all right uh
what do you got because
i want to make sure i've got it that's
it i'm good it's called nerf legends by
the way i'll end it on a high note
is it nerf ultimate is what it's nerf
legends
nerf legends thank you yes
what are you doing man
against carol salute man good for
pulling up always fun to have you man
he's been there
since the the flash flashpoint data you
guys got the name is from
you uh that's how i met abontis yes
because we used to have a
talk thing i don't know it was like when
i was a smaller streamer
and then we stopped and then abontus
reached out and he was like hey dude can
i use the name i was like sure yeah
it was right it was you i said we had to
get the og that's right i forgot about
that he was like yeah bro no problem
you're totally cool about it you know i
think i was on like one
i think like really early because yeah
you were i looked back through like my
record of like who i have like somewhat
recently from a while back and like you
weren't on that list i was like i know
he had you but it's been a while so
definitely good to go
brother always good to have you yeah any
time i i love doing this and just
chatting and you know
whatever dude yeah no doubt but you have
me at lockhart you know on twitter all
that good stuff um defining duke had a
monster episode with randolph dawn
boy how long
pretty long like a little you know a
little three hour special
maybe close to five days so long i don't
even remember now but um bro it was lit
though it was late i ain't gonna go
front like we had a good time salute to
him talking all that good stuff shout
out to maddie plays so check that out
again it's up on patreon if you don't
want to do that you can wait till it's
free 99 on sunday and get it on the
youtube or last stand media check that
out also please stay tuned the lords of
gaming.net a lot of special stuff
cooking up big stuff soon so check out
that and then iron lords podcast this
sunday y'all we got a big one come hang
out we will be with the legendary jason
ronald will be pulling up we're gonna
talk you know one year anniversary of
the uh series x we'll talk about xbox
20th anniversary obviously halo
multiplayer drop so it's gonna be like a
big xbox love fest so come through
check it out king david would be crazy i
can help you already know you know
like whenever phil gets on there i think
oh god king is gonna just like either
die or break him i don't know how it's
going to go only a matter of time
yeah i was like you've got jason ronald
you've had a couple other people phil's
phil's going to get there like you'll
that'll that'll have have to happen yeah
oh also one wants to like i got you bro
yeah man come check it it should be a
fun show that'll be on sunday 11 a.m
eastern and again all the new platform
stuff all the all the stuff going on in
the um with both series consoles just
kind of like a celebration just bugging
out having a good time so come check us
out and of course even though he doesn't
like me say hit the like button
subscribe to that uh that last word that
ivanta's youtube channel come check it
out guys tell your friends you know all
your friends leave a review on all audio
platforms yes please do it's a fun show
we love doing it travis you the homie
it's been even more fun since you got
here and um i'm loving it loving what
we're doing man continuing up the good
work e what you got going on besides an
amazing match video that y'all all need
to hit subscribe like you put on that
video watch it now yes please e talk to
him uh yeah so just been working on kind
of guides that are going to be
universally useful for a little while so
just upgrade materials course right now
by the way it's like literally my number
one in the video anyway if you made it
this far in the video and you managed to
listen to it you can go do hero level
nightfalls i got like anywhere from
three to five enhancement cores one to
two prisms every run yeah hollow there's
a little like a little annoying but in
12 minutes you can farm those easily
like dude you gotta clickbait it you
gotta click you gotta be like hey if you
wanna know the easiest way to get five
prisms go watch this video throw it in
chat there you go teach the boy how to
click bait
oh i mean you know there's an art you
know we gotta have he too nice we gotta
click bait let's go yeah
there's there's different forms of click
baiting but you gotta leave them wanting
more and yeah always use ellipses if you
can this is the best
endgame material farm in destiny
and then just you and the thumbnail
going
you know
boom
got to start a kit right there yes yes
perfect but yeah still just basically
like working on kind of guides in this
downtime that like how to solo champions
did a guide on those just basically
stuff that like if you tune in at some
point you'll be able to find something
beneficial from it for trying to help
out new people i still i was actually
talking to
somebody and there's a point where i
want to do i want to find somebody who
wants to play destiny but has literally
never touched it
and what i want to do is
what you don't count
me you don't count but no it's like and
on because i'm really curious because we
had swifty on and he was talking about
making a free account but i want to like
sit there and just like in discord like
you know an hour or so every so often
just play with somebody who has never
played it to see how confusing this game
is for somebody who has no clue what's
going on because dude like
we take so much for granted
i can only imagine they're like well
what's this well why is this who is that
who are they talking about what's like
it would be like i swear an infinite
thing like i don't know how i could do
that series or who i could ever find but
like that would be
just absolutely insane i think just
because people would be so clueless but
yeah always just on youtube whether it's
streaming on twitch if i get to variety
later i'm still waiting on my monitor
across my fingers it's at least on you
know the la coast and then hopefully
it'll get shipped to me soon and we'll
see how that goes finally getting a 4k
144 monitor so
gonna be a little i've been 60 frames
per second forever so i might actually
get high frames so let's go
let's go yeah that's been long overdue
so i don't even have how many uh how
many monitors are you using your setup
two right now so it'll be my third
oh you're going for three nice that's
the i think that's the sweet spot yeah
because then like my old 1080 which is
the one straight in front of me here
would probably be vertical for chat if i
want it then you got the uh so yeah
that's the goal is
nice hello but yeah other than that just
like same as these guys we're kind of in
the lull before the 30th and trying to
catch up on the backlog if i get a
chance to
oh
we're going for world's first on the
dungeon that's what i'm doing there we
go
i have a baller team we're gonna go and
then uh also in the downtown i'm gonna
be trying to solo eight tracks because
i've never done that it's the easiest
solo i think oh wow that's good so
absolutely life doesn't seem to think
you're gonna go world first on the
dungeons
she's like yeah the teammates are subpar
not seeing it she she doesn't know that
much about destiny so i just thought i
got this i just let her kind of talk to
herself it'll be fine
there we go hey about this what if i get
my wife to play and try to understand
what's going on with that there we go
there we go
she's like okay dude like literally i
had her play um so i forget what it
might have been destiny and she was like
or no it was call of duty it's trying to
she like couldn't walk through doors no
this is gonna be perfect i mean my i
played it takes two with my wife and
absolutely she's not like she played
like some stuff growing up like mario
kart another like she's played and she
kills me in tetris she's amazing at
tetris and beat saber so that's fine um
but like we played it takes two and
that's if you've never done a twin stick
shooter like or two like on controller
it's no joke if you've never done it so
like there's points where i'm like
lapping the arena making sure she gets
like rezzed up but like we made it
through the whole thing together and i
was actually really happy about that but
i was like yeah her playing destiny
would be the same way i've joked i'm
like
yeah like complete clueless destiny
person it's it would be
you got to say you got to say honey
honey honey for the clout
that's all you have to say do it for the
clown i was like what if this is like
the video that takes off babe what if
this is the series
this is it golden goose you're sitting
there you just gotta put you put each
other like both you guys in the
thumbnail there's a girl in your
thumbnail so your click rate goes eighty
percent
well uh for episode number 174 this has
been an absolute blast we rambled on
here in the end this is like the last
word after dark uh not to steal from rgh
but yeah definitely a fun piece here but
thank you guys scaro always a
pleasurable try not to make it so long
and getting you on because it's been too
long so
definitely a fun show with you travis of
course good luck in the nerf wars
and i'm very interested in
like a little surprise gym
or it's going to be like how low
like asking your boss like how low can i
score a game i how what's the lowest
score that ign can give like it's one of
those two because i don't see it being
just like oh it's a six it's either a
two or a nine and i don't think it's a
whole lot in between
and then i'm definitely gonna tag you in
my review yes please please please tag
all of us like i will retweet this thing
and i'm watching it i want to see and
then cog of course man dude yeah awesome
yeah go check out iron lords podcast
lords of gaming.net please hang out in
their live chat be decent but definitely
blow up that chat for this man because
that's a huge guest so awesome stuff uh
so yeah episode number 174 november 18th
as we wrap this thing up thank you guys
all chat has been amazing tell your
friends leave the reviews drop the likes
all the good things for all of these
amazing people and for this episode it
has been
the last word